bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mardi 5 janvier 500
pour les pompiers et les aides à
domicile de plus de 50 ans listes
d'inscription pour les volontaires à
l'antidote centres de vaccination après
les critiques sur la lenteur de la
campagne vaccinale olivier veyron
accélère la cadence à la veille d'un
nouveau conseil de défense et sous la
pression des manuels maquereau en
déplacement à tours aujourd'hui le
conseil d'état valide l'élargissement
des fichiers de renseignement rejetant
ainsi les requêtes de syndicats qui
dénonçaient la dangerosité de ces
fichiers
les forces de l'ordre pourront
renseigner les opinions politiques
l'appartenance syndicale et les données
de santé au nom de la sûreté de l'état
outre atlantique une double élections
sénatoriales cruciales en géorgie donald
trump et joe biden ont soutenu leur
candidat hier soir un scrutin à l'impact
décisif pour le début de mandat du
président élu démocrate
donald trump lui refuse toujours de
reconnaître les résultats
ses partisans s'apprêtent à converger à
nouveau vers washington pour le soutenir
[Musique]
cela devait être un rendez vous
quotidien le bilan de la campagne de
vaccination devait être publié chaque
jour à compter d'aujourd'hui mais cela a
finalement pris du retard l'exécutif a
promis d' amplifier sa stratégie
vaccinale alors où en est-on quelles
sont les dernières annonces sur le front
de la vaccination
on fait le point tout de suite en direct
devant le ministère de la santé avec
estelle farges
bonsoir estelle après le triptyque
tester tracé isolé quels sont les
nouveaux mots d'ordre amplifié et
accéléré simplifié à stéphanie se sont
lé nouveau mot d'ordre de la stratégie
vaccinale de la france contre le coc
vite 19 une précision seimat ce matin à
d'olivier véran le ministre de la santé
qui a tenu à afficher la volonté de
l'exécutif d'accélérer la cadence ans
après avoir essuyé de nombreuses
critiques sur la lenteur de la mise en
place de la campagne de vaccination
olivier veyrat qui a tenté de rassurer
le rythme de croisière du pays va
rejoindre celui de nos voisins européens
ce sont à ces mots car la france en est
à la traîne sur le nombre de vaccinés
dans le pays
alors du côté des annonces et bien hier
le cap des 2000 vacciner a été franchie
la liste des personnes éligibles au
vaccin s'élargit elle aussi en petit à
petit après les soignants de plus de 50
ans hier place dans les prochains jours
aux pompiers et aux aides soignants de
plus de 50 ans et puis avant la fin du
mois de janvier les plus de 75 ans qui
ne résident pas en ehpad pour on peut
aussi se faire vacciner
et puis sachez que 5 à 600 centres de
vaccination devraient voir le jour en
ville à la fin du mois merci et celle
farges mais avant cela le premier
ministre un estelle qui est aussi sur le
fond pour défendre la stratégie du
gouvernement
[Musique]
exactement depuis toulon où il était en
déplacement jean castex a fustigé des
polémiques stériles qui n'ont jamais
sauvé aucune vie ce sont en ces mots le
premier ministre qui a indiqué qu'il
tiendrait une conférence de presse aux
côtés d'olivier vers en avant un conseil
de défense et un conseil des ministres
qui eux se dérouleront mercredi
enfin sachez qu olivier vers ans sera
entendue au sénat le 12 janvier prochain
pour s'expliquer sur les mesures
correctives mises en place par le
gouvernement pour pallier la lenteur de
la france sur le front de la vaccination
et merci et self argent direct donc du
ministère de la santé et dans ce
contexte on apprend qu'une dizaine de
personnes sont contaminées ou suspectées
d'être infectées en france par le
variant du corona virus identifié au
royaume uni annonce aujourd'hui
d'olivier ferrand lors d'une interview à
nos confrères d'rtl
certaines de ces personnes ont été mises
en quarantaine selon le ministre de la
santé et le variant du coville la
situation sanitaire en france la
stratégie de vaccination on en parle
avec le professeur élites comme chef du
service des maladies infectieuses de la
pitié salpêtrière à paris c'est notre
rubrique l'invité que ce soit
[Musique]
bonsoir hélico merci à beaucoup d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france le
variant donc du coc vie de 19 ans qui
affole angleterre est désormais en
france en ile-de-france même une dizaine
de cas ont été détectés
doit-on sont inquiétés bruit on doit
fondre inquiété parce qu'apparemment il
est quand même un peu plus contagieux
que le virus qui circulent et auxquels
on est habitué depuis plusieurs mois
donc s'il est plus contagieux il va se
transmettre plus facilement s'ils se
transmet plus facilement eelv a infecté
plus de personnes s'il infecte plus de
personnes y aura plus de cas graves qui
rentreront réanimation donc en fait
c'est un problème de dénominateur et si
ce virus donne plus de cas il y aura
forcément plus de personnes qui
rentreront en réanimation
c'est vrai qu'en angleterre on a aussi
parlé du fait que les jeunes étaient
davantage dans les enfants étaient
davantage contaminées par cette mutation
du virus ça veut dire logiquement quoi
qu'on va également devoir fermer les
écoles et peut-être confinés comme les
anglais en france bon à l'écouté je
pense qu'il est un peu trop tôt pour
dire ce qu'il faudra faire le virus on
sait très bien qui circule parmi les
enfants dans les écoles les collèges les
lycées
on a toujours 10 ont minimisé
l'importance de cette transmission en
milieu scolaire s'il s'avère que ce
nouveau variant circule mieux en milieu
scolaire c'est sûr qu'une des
conséquences pour être d'envisager la
fermeture des écoles mais je rappelle
que dans la plupart des pays qui ont
pris des dispositions fortes pour
empêcher cette épidémie d'évoluer une
des premières fermetures c'était une des
premières décisions pardon c'était de
fermer les écoles et c'est ce qu'ils ont
fait en allemagne par exemple
alors on dit tout et son contraire on
lit tout et son contraire sur le côté
pathogènes de cette mutation aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous pouvez nous rassurer que
ce variant finalement n'est pas plus
dangereux que entre guillemets l'ancien
virus oui je pense qu'on peut on peut
rassurer bon même s'il est encore un peu
trop tôt pour rassurer définitivement
je rappelle que ce nouveau variant a
émergé il ya même pas à moi donc il est
quand même encore un peu tôt pour se
faire une idée exacte mais en tout cas
on sait que ce virus mute limite de
façon régulière quotidienne
là ce qui est un peu inhabituel c'est le
nombre de mutations qui a mais bon c'est
logique dans la vie d'un virus de muter
bon je pense qu'il faut pas s'en
inquiéter outre mesure en tout cas alors
on entendait évidemment que le niveau de
la france pour le moment n'est pas au
niveau du royaume uni ni même de
l'allemagne est ce que selon vous on
peut empêcher justement cette hausse
inquiétante des contaminés dans notre
pays est ce qu'on arrivera à se
maintenir
on connaît les on connaît les recettes
pour empêcher les contaminations c'est
c'est de tester tracé isolé je crois
qu'il faut pas oublier l'importance
cette stratégie c'est pas parce qu'on
commence à vacciner qu'il faut oublier
les autres composantes de la prévention
individuelle et collective
c'est à dire rappelé les mesures
barrières
rappelé l'importance de s'isoler quand
on est malade de se tester régulièrement
de tracer les cas positifs
je pense que c'est ça qui est important
a rappelé et puis elle vaccin qui
arrivait donc tout ça va va permettre
d'améliorer les choses
le vexin qui arrive évidemment 516
personnes pour le moment c'est toujours
le chiffre officiel donné par les
autorités même si olivier ferrand voile
a affirmé qu'il y avait peut-être 2000
personnes en plus de vacciner une chose
est sûre c'est que le chiffre reste
officiel reste à 516 en janvier il
faudra appliquer 33000 perse 33 mille
personnes par jour pour maintenir
l'objectif ambitieux du gouvernement est
ce qu'on va y arriver selon vous
pourquoi autant de lenteur est ce qu on
s'y prend mal
on écoute et je crois que c'est un peu
trop tôt pour dire qu'on s'y prend mal
enfin même si effectivement ça a mal
débuté on va pas on va pas tourner
autour du pot
je pense qu'il ya un problème de
disponibilité quand même du vaccin c'est
à dire que démarré pied au plancher en
vaccinant des centaines de milliers de
personnes
si vous n'avez pas le vaccin à votre
disposition c'est quand même difficile
de le faire donc je pense que c'est pour
ça que ça a démarré doucement enfin
j'ose espérer que c'est pour ça que
c'est pas pour d'autres raisons
les d'aucune façon il faut être vaccinés
c'est impératif
c'est la seule manière de 2
à titre individuel de ne pas être
hospitalisées et de ne pas rentrer en
réanimation et à titre collectif de
mettre fin à cette épidémie le plus
rapidement possible doctor comme
professeur comme vous nous dites le
vaccin n'est pas disponible pourtant le
ministre de la santé nous dit que voilà
il ya des centaines de milliers de doses
déjà disponibles sur le territoire donc
ça veut dire quoi roues sont elles ces
doses de vaccin réécoutez pourrait tout
à fait précis je ne je ne sais pas où
sont les doses de vaccin je n'ai je n'ai
je vous avoue que c'est moi je regarde
ce qui arrive dans mon service et je
peux vous dire que ça arrive on a
commencé à vacciner aujourd'hui on
augmentera la capacité de vaccination
demain et on augmentera encore après
demain et c'est comme ça que ça va se
passer dans plusieurs endroits de france
et même un peu partout en france
moi j'ai plutôt envie de voir les choses
comme ça positive on démarre peut-être
doucement mais si on accélère comme il
faut eh bien on arrivera je l'espère aux
objectifs fixés le plus rapidement
possible en sachant qu évidemment il va
falloir augmenter le rythme et la
cadence est évident mais effectivement
parce qu'on est on est sérieusement en
retard certains députés a notamment les
républicains ont proposé un allègement
du consentement notamment est ce que
vous pensez que ça serait l'une des
pistes pour accélérer la cadence
ben oui il ya un problème avec le
consentement effectivement c'est à dire
que quand à partir du moment où on a
décidé de vacciner dans les ehpad
on a complètement oublié que dans les
ehpad y avait des personnes qui
n'avaient plus toutes leurs capacités
intellectuelles et que donc il fallait
veut prendre contact avec des tuteurs
pour pouvoir obtenir le consentement et
ça ça n'avait pas été anticipée
apparemment et donc effectivement il ya
une perte de temps mais de toute façon
la vaccination dans les ehpad n'est pas
la clé de la réussite pour diminuer
l'importance de la rapidité de
l'épidémie il faut vacciner beaucoup
plus largement dans les ehpad pour cela
est-ce qu'on va devoir passer comme le
fait l'allemagne par des ces fameux
vaccinodromes qui ne vont pas forcément
réussi par par le passé on n'y coupera
pas ses grands centres de vaccination
écoutez je pense que c'est la solution
effectivement plutôt que d'éparpiller
les centres de vaccination un peu
partout en multipliant les endroits on
se vaccine je pense qu'il vaudrait mieux
faire des grands centres de vaccination
qu'on appelle vaccinodromes si vous
voulez et dans lequel on puisse vacciner
du matin au soir
le plus de monde possible et dans les
meilleures conditions de sécurité
wissam apparaître le plus le plus adapté
à la situation
je voulais qu'on parle de la stratégie
de l'agencé européenne des médicaments
qui a un rôle extrêmement important en
ce moment ci vaccin retenu près de 2
milliards de doses précommander vaccin
moderne et classique confondues on va
les voir s'afficher sur l'écran on
s'aperçoit qu'il y a donc qu'un seul
vaccin disponible et de valider par
l'agencé européenne des médicaments pour
injection les autres sanofi on n'en
parle pas un qui a pris un retard
considérable astrazeneca également les
discussions qui vont reprendre mercredi
sur le modern as qu' il ya une
défaillance de stratégie au niveau de la
commission européenne
on a mal peut-être commander les doses
on aurait dû mieux faire on a décidé
britanniques et les états unis
le champ libre pour se procurer
davantage de vaccins
ben il faut pas oublier quand même que
ces vaccins ont été fabriquées aux états
unis et en angleterre pour ce qui
concerne le vaccin astrazeneca donc les
premiers ce sont les premiers servis
donc c'est pas très surprenant ensuite
l'agencé européenne du médicament elle
fait son travail correctement
c'est à dire qu'elle prend le temps
d'analyser les données des vaccins elle
a analysé le vaccin de pfizer à peu près
très rapidement puisque elle a même
donné elle a même rendu un avis une
semaine après que l'article principal
était publié une dizaine de jours après
que l'agencé américaine du médicament et
rendu un avis favorable
donc moi je trouve qu'ils vont assez
vite simplement ils peuvent pas aller
plus vite que la musique
et on comprend très bien on peut pas à
la fois reproché aux décideurs d'être
trop lent et leur reprocher d'être trop
rapide analyse et des dossiers
d'enregistrement de médicaments et a
fortiori de vaccin qui va être utilisé à
des millions de dhs exemplaire pour des
millions de personnes
on peut pas prendre ces décisions en
cinq minutes un c'est absolument évident
pour des projets comprend qu'ils
prennent leur temps en tout cas certains
pays sont allés plus vite 108 face donc
à ces autorisations données
c'est le cas du royaume-uni qui a fait
le pari d'une doses pour vacciner le
plus possible et le plus vite
c'est le cas également du du danemark
c'est un pari médical ou un pari
logistique au choix qui peut être risqué
selon vous pour l'instant c'est trop tôt
pour le dire il faudra pouvoir comparer
dans six mois par exemple les pays qui
ont choisi cette stratégie vaccinale
en fait ils vont faire la deuxième
vaccination ils vont faire le deuxième
injection
mais simplement au lieu de la faire au
bout de trois semaines ou d'un mois ils
vont la faire au bout de deux trois ou
de trois mois environ je me rappelle
plus exactement les délais ils vont la
faire avec retard par rapport au schéma
qui avait été préconisée au départ dont
on pourra comparer entre un schéma
classique et puis un schéma retardé pour
voir le résultat à l'arrivée la halle
avantage pour eux c'est qu'ils vont
pouvoir vacciner beaucoup plus
rapidement beaucoup plus de personnes
voilà l'inconvénient c'est qu'il faut
qu'ils aient des deuxièmes noces qui
suivent parce que s'ils n'ont pas de
deuxième dose qui suivent et bien
l'immunité va disparaître il faudra tout
recommencer à zéro
donc il faut pas se rater au niveau de
l'espace entre deux injections alors
l'une des informations du jour c'est
cette possible coopération entre la
russie et l'allemagne vladimir poutine
et angela merkel qui évoque une possible
production conjointe de vaccin ça vous
semble être une bonne nouvelle
bah écoute et oui évidemment que c'est
une bonne nouvelle tout ce qui peut
permettre de de produire plus rapidement
et de vacciner le plus rapidement
possible est évidemment une bonne
nouvelle on ne peut que s'en réjouir
après je ne sais pas si les allemands
vont fabriquer le vaccin rue soucy des
russes ont fabriqué un vaccin allemand
je sais pas vraiment dans quel sens ça
marche je pense que c'est plutôt les
allemands qui vont je sais pas je ne
sais pas dans quel sens ça marche mais
je sais que les russes ont aussi prévu
de de travail et que les indiens donc
oui c'est bien qu'ils aient une cette
coopération internationale qui se passe
moi je trouve ça super alors ma dernière
question aux professeurs on parle en ce
moment que des vaccins quasiment et plus
trop d des médicaments est ce que il ya
encore de l'espoir dans ce domaine alors
effectivement vous avez raison de poser
cette question de la même que manière
que je trouvais que le vaccin occulte un
peu les autres aspects de la prévention
notamment testé tracé isolé je trouve
qu'effectivement le vaccin au culte
aussi
la recherche des médicaments efficaces
contre le virus
mais il faut savoir que c'est pas par
hasard c'est parce que à ce stade du
développement malheureusement on n'a pas
de médicaments qui émerge comme
antiviral efficace ou comme médicaments
qui permettent de faire un progrès
définitif en manière de prise en charge
des malades et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
vraiment insisté sur l'importance de la
vaccination et l'importance de la
prévention
parce qu'actuellement on stagne en ce
qui concerne l'aspect curatif et ça pose
d'énormes problèmes notamment non
seulement en termes de mortalité mais
aussi en terme de durée
d'hospitalisation d'embouteillage des
services de spitalier classique et de
réanimation
merci beaucoup professeur éric comme
chef du service des maladies
infectieuses de la pitié salpêtrière à
paris merci d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france la campagne de
vaccination française critique et donc
pour sa lenteur seulement 516 enlisé
vaccination officiel à ce jour ce qui
pousse certains maires à vouloir prendre
la main sur ce dossier
des élus qui souhaitent agir au niveau
des territoires en proposant des centres
de vaccination et des moyens logistiques
écoutez la réaction de damien allouche
maire ps d'epinay sous sénart dans
l'essonne nous avons acquis l'expérience
depuis maintenant malheureusement depuis
le mois de juin au mois de mars nous
avons acquis une certaine expérience
d'organisation nous avons acquis un
certain pragmatisme que nous avons
travaillé avec notamment les
professionnels de santé
nous avons appris à travailler
différemment et aujourd'hui si on devait
aider à mettre en place la campagne de
vaccination nous saurions le faire en
lien avec les professionnels de santé en
lien avec la préfecture en lien avec
avec nos partenaires nous serons le
faire le département de l'essonne c'est
un vaste département vous avez des très
grandes communes comme every vous avez
des et toutes petites communes dans le
sud de l'essonne mais chacun a sa part
pourra en tout cas a fait ses preuves en
tout cas de volontarisme dans les
différents messages qu'on pût être
échangé les uns avec les autres si on
nous avait appelé il ya trois ou quatre
semaines pour nous dire voilà on met en
place une stratégie
de vaccination à six semaines quelle
drôle pourriez vous jouez à quel moment
vous pourriez de jouer à savoir là où on
aurait pu accompagner la stratégie de
vaccination il dire voilà ce qui se
passe quand les chiffres tombent du
nombre de vaccinés en allemagne hors
d'israël dans d'autres endroits du globe
et quand on regarde les chiffres lundi
matin ou dimanche du nombre de vaccinés
en france
évidemment ça qu'ils se donnent plus que
toi même plus que ça questionne ça
interroge voir ses amis certains élus
extrêmement en colère
moi je me prémunir cette colère je reste
concentré sur ce que j'ai à faire je
reste pragmatique jeu depuis le début de
la crise vous avez un beau père et moi
je fais pas partie du du même parti
politique quel présent de la république
je considère que pendant cette crise qui
est particulièrement anxiogène
la multiplication des attaques accentue
cette ce volet on chez jet certains le
font très bien et sait très bien qu'ils
le fassent et l'aspect démocratique mais
jusqu'à maintenant dans mes réseaux
autour de moi j'ai toujours fait très
attention à ne pas être dans cette danse
est cette réflexion-là énoncé part seul
vers vos là depuis dimanche
je ne pouvais plus me taire et il
fallait dire à ce moment là que nous
sommes là et qu'il faut que que sur
cette stratégie conçois qu'on vienne
nous voir comment nous poser des
questions pour savoir qu'elle est de
notre point de vue j'ai pas qu'on a
raison je dis qu'elle est de notre point
de vue qu'elle serait là vers des
stratégies à adopter pour rendre la
stratégie de vaccination la plus
efficace et pour évoquer cette campagne
vaccinale française dans son aspect
politique nous retrouvons alexis pour
lancer notre rubrique l'édito
[Musique]
bonsoir alexis poulain merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france l'exécutif dit tout
et son contraire
oui alors c'est vrai qu'on a entendu
beaucoup de choses ces derniers jours à
la fois monsieur vaccin monsieur futur
qui était rassurant disant que ce rythme
lent été voulue c'était pour rassurer
les français
et puis on apprend dans le jdd kemmel
macron était dans une colère noire que
ça n'allait pas assez vite
jean castex le premier ministre quant à
lui il disait simplement que ce n'est
pas du retard c'est simplement du
décalage et que le gouvernement français
suit un chemin le chemin de la
vaccination
on espère que ce sera pas l'équivalent
du chemin des dames en 14-18 parce que
là ce serait quand même à une hécatombe
si c'était le cas et puis si on regarde
les chiffres là on est en plein dans la
contradiction par rapport à ce qui a été
dit le discours de jean castex le 16
décembre à l'assemblée nationale pour
présenter cette fameuse stratégie
la livraison des doses d'ici la fin
décembre
la france devait recevoir un million
cent soixante mille doses puis suit 177
mille doses supplémentaires autour du 5
et du 6 janvier et enfin 1 million 600
mille doses supplémentaires en février
or qu'est ce qu'a dit olivier ferrand le
ministre de la santé à l'hôtel-dieu
lundi nous avons reçu cinq cent mille
doses et nous en attendons 580 1000
d'ici mercredi donc on est loin du
compte
on se demande où sont passés les doses
est ce qu'il ya eu trop d'effets
d'annoncé ce que cette campagne
finalement elle a été d'abord mis sur la
communication avant d'être mis sur la
logistique et la vaccination alors face
aux critiques le gouvernement promet
d'accélérer et de simplifier est-ce que
cela se concrétise alors accéléré
c'est ce qui a été annoncé aujourd'hui
par olivier ferrand 7000 vaccination
mais on est loin du compte bien entendu
seulement eu 27 hôpitaux une trentaine
d'hôpitaux qui ont été livrées ça fait
peu sur le nombre d'hôpitaux pour
pouvoir se faire vacciner
en revanche pour la parole politique sur
les plateaux de télévision
alors là oui les ténors de la majorité
sont accéléré le pas et on a pu voir
gabriel attali
vers ans jean castex mails mâcon qui a
pris la parole de manière détournée mais
clairement la gestion en bon père de
famille a été mis de côté
la stratégie de la tortue aussi
maintenant il faut aller vite et puis on
apprend aussi que c'est un cabinet de
conseil le cabinet mckinsey qui est en
charge de cette stratégie vaccinale
on sait déjà que c'était le cabinet
belge à une compagnie qui avait été
chargé par jean castex a l'époque
monsieur déconfinement du déconfinement
à chaque fois on a l'impression que ces
gens qui sont quand même payé par nos
impôts à faire beaucoup de choses et
bien se tourner vers le privé pour
organiser des choses à leur place et ils
découvrent finalement que au coeur de la
stratégie vaccinale plutôt que de mettre
des grands pontes de la médecine
il fallait des logisticiens des gens qui
étaient capables d'acheminer les doses
de vaccins d'un point a à un point b
avec ses super congélateur bien sûr
qu'ils sont la clé puisque les vaccins
de votre texte
gardez au frais à moins 80 degrés et
puis et puis chez les soignants bien on
commence à s'inquiéter avec une tribune
demandant plus de clarté dans cette
stratégie vaccinale puisque encore une
fois jean castex allez promis de la
transparence
or transparence il n'y en a pas ni sur
les honoraires de mc kids est ni sur le
nombre de doses qui sont sur le
territoire ni sur le rythme à laquelle
cette vaccination va se mettre en place
alors raté la campagne de vaccination
est ce que cela pourrait signifier la
fin politique d' emmanuel macron où
c'est peut-être exagéré alors peut-être
pas sa fin politique puisque en
politique rien n'est jamais fini
sauf vraiment à la toute fin mais ça
pourrait sérieusement mettre en doute
une potentielle candidature pour
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 22
parce que quel bilan aurait-il à
défendre sur cette gestion sanitaire il
ya eu la cacophonie et le fiasco des
masques et le fiasco des tests le fiasco
maintenant de du début de vaccination on
va voir comment ça se passe par la suite
mais on a l'impression que c'est conseil
de défense ils ne servent à rien à part
assuré le secret défense
et au final le dire mais comment est
gérée finalement la politique sanitaire
en france est aujourd'hui tout va se
tourner bien sûr vers cette politique
sanitaire et je crois que le quoi qu'il
en coûte
demel macron valent peut-être lui coûter
cher parce que on est en train de fermer
des secteurs entiers de la société
secteur de la culture c'est que la nuit
de la restauration les bars c'est
beaucoup d' aide beaucoup d'entreprises
qui hélas est malheureusement vont faire
faillite
beaucoup de gens qui vont se retrouver
au chômage une croissance qui ne risque
pas d'être au rendez vous le quoi qu'il
en coûte risque d'être un tout ça pour
ça qui va coûter extrêmement cher à
emmanuel macron mais aussi à sa majorité
alors sans compter qu'un nouveau
scandale politique est en vue pour le
président on a appris aujourd'hui
l'ancien ministre de la santé agnès
buzyn entre au cabinet du directeur
général de l'om est ce ce sont ses
compétences qui sont reconnues alors si
ces compétences pourquoi pas agnès buzyn
c'est elle qui disait que tout allait
bien que ce virus n'était pas là encore
sur le territoire européen
c'est à dire comme ça qu'elle organise
sa défense devant la commission d'
enquête parlementaire en disant que
finalement
tout ce qu'elle a fait est parfait
puisqu'il n'y avait pas de virus à
l'époque où il était aux commandes
c'est elle qui a mis des affiches à
l'aéroport pour accueillir le virus en
provenance du monde entier
c'est elle qui n'a pas recommandé les
masses quand elle savait que ça n'allait
pas qu'ils savaient dès décembre que
quelque chose n'allait pas qui parlait
du fiasco de la mascarade des élections
municipales
la voilà récompensés on est dans ce
qu'on appelle une cas qui stockera si
c'est à dire que ce sont les plus
médiocres qui sont récompensés il s'agit
là des xi litres et agnès buzyn sans
doute de lui promettre un poste à
l'étranger c'est ce dont elle rêvait
pour garder le silence pour aussi être
protégés sans doute des journalistes
français trop curieux qui lui poserait
beaucoup de questions sur cette gestion
de crise parce que ses réponses devant
la commission denquête finalement on peu
satisfait les députés qui étaient devant
elle donc voilà la faillite morale
finalement de ce gouvernement qui refuse
la responsabilité qui va de pair avec
les devoirs de des élus et des
politiques
il s'agit de fuir on a eu lors de la
crise et du scandale du sang contaminé
responsable mais pas coupable
on a maintenant avec ce gouvernement ni
responsable ni coupable
courage fuyons la suite nous dira ce
qu'il en sera puisqu'il ya toujours de
nombreuses plaintes qui sont en cours
vis-à-vis d'eux
madame un butin mais également de
l'ancien premier ministre edouard
philippe et d'autres responsables de ces
fiascos à répétition
donc la suite au prochain numéro mais
c'est vraiment aujourd'hui si nous
sommes en guerre
une déroute qui nous est proposée par ce
gouvernement merci alexis poulain rester
avec nous dans quelques instants nous
parlerons du conseil d'état qui valide
l'élargissement des fichiers de
renseignement rejetant les requêtes de
syndicats qui dénonçaient la dangerosité
de ces fichiers
et puis direction les états unis où la
majorité au sénat est suspendu à deux
batailles en géorgie à un scrutin qui
aura un impact décisif sur le début de
mandat de joe biden
[Musique]
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française
c'était après les attentats du 11
septembre et quand on vient vous voir et
qu'on vous dit ben écoutez vous avez de
la première femme qui allait rentrer
dans ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu qu' pas voilà c'est fini pour
moi est ce que ça remet en armes
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça du majeur mais
quel est le rapport avec la réducation
mais fait pas radicalisation il faut que
nous reprenions la place dans le cerveau
des enfants et de la jeunesse
[Musique]
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
sur les pas en appartement et hervé on a
le sentiment qu'il faut à chaque fois se
battre ils vivent parfois au bord des
routes nationales pas forcément loin de
paris mais toujours loin de ceux qui les
dirigent
ma joseph mâcon il passe un tour de
tracts avec toute leur campagne il faut
savoir c'est une différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles bas pourrait t'aider quoi un
peu plus aujourd'hui la france oubliée
c'est montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
c'est un coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent la
haine en soi vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrême
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview 20h30 soit et
les bienvenus en direct sur rt france
désarroi des syndicats au lendemain de
l'annoncé de la décision du conseil
d'état de rejeter leur recours contre
l'élargissement des fichiers de
renseignement opinions publiques données
de santé engagements syndicaux seront
désormais référencée au nom de la
sécurité de l'état les précisions de la
cour administrative depuis la cour
administrative avec katia technique
le conseil d'état a donné raison au
gouvernement
désormais la police et la gendarmerie
pourront ficher des données telles que
l'appartenance syndicale ou politique
des renseignements sur la santé de très
nombreuses voix politique militante
associative s'était élevé contre ces
décrets alors plusieurs organisations
syndicales comme la cgt et fo la fsu
avait saisi le conseil d'état en urgence
est bien celui ci a estimé que la
collecte de ces données ne constituait
pas une atteinte à la liberté d'opinion
de conscience la liberté syndicale ou
encore la liberté de religion c'est à
dire que désormais police et gendarmerie
pourront collecter des photos ou des
commentaires sur les réseaux sociaux
toute une foule de détails qui ne
figurait pas sur les fichiers
cela représente 50 types de données en
tout trois décrets pour trois types de
fichiers qui regroupe des dizaines de
milliers de personnes
alors jusqu'ici ces fichiers servait à
identifier des manifestants violent
encore des supporters de foot violent
désormais ils serviront aussi à
identifier des personnes susceptibles de
commettre un acte terroriste ou encore
et c'est là que le bât blesse de porter
atteinte à l'intégrité du territoire ou
aux institutions de la république et
cela laisse une grande marge de
manoeuvre que qui gênent énormément les
opposants à ce texte
on se rappelle qu'en 2008 françois
fillon avait dû reculer en voulant
instaurer un nouveau type de fichage le
fichier edvige sous la pression
populaire et aujourd'hui c'est un autre
type de big brother qui se profile la
palme a tonné avocat au conseil d'état
justement et à la cour de kassel
si on énonce une utilisation
d'instruments disproportionnée que
l'état se dote d'un instrument pour
lutter contre les troubles à l'ordre
public contre la délinquance contre le
terrorisme contre les atteintes à la
sûreté
c'est tout à fait normal en revanche il
faut que ces instruments soient
proportionnées et qui est des garanties
des garanties données à chacun d'entre
nous puisque c'est chacun d'entre nous
qui est susceptible de faire l'objet
d'une collecte des données pour peu que
son comportement soit interprété comme
constituant une atteinte à une en tout
cas comme pouvant porter atteinte à la
sécurité publique
l'appartenance syndicale que ce jusqu à
ce que je sache il n'y a pas de violence
urbaine de terrorisme syndicats ce n'est
pas la barre dans ce syndicat n'a rien à
voir avec la prévention de des atteintes
à la sécurité publique et à la sûreté de
l'état et de la même manière lorsque
l'administration peut connecter des
éléments sur la vie les habitudes de vie
le terme très floue du décret eh bien on
ouvre la porte à des comportement
arbitraire et pour en parler nous sommes
avec bruno bartocetti sgp police fo
secrétaire zone sud bonsoir bruno
bartocetti merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france c'est plutôt une
bonne nouvelle bien accueillie par la
police cette décision du conseil d'état
bonsoir et merci de m'avoir invité
la première la première question est ce
qu'on doit faire confiance au juge des
référés qui finalement abonde dans ce
sens aujourd'hui on doit justement faire
confiance à notre justice
et si celle ci se prononce favorablement
on peut en discuter mais on peut aussi
se montrer confiant vous savez
ce soir vous avez en face de vous un
syndicaliste mais aussi un policier
d'abord un policier ensuite un
syndicaliste et je crois que ce qui est
important c'est de ne pas être frileux
en matière de fichiers des contenances
le mot fichier en france on peut
comprendre mais sur notre notre histoire
notre histoire fait mal lorsqu'on parle
de fichiers mais est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
on travaille comme lors du siècle
dernier je ne crois pas je crois
qu'aujourd'hui les fichiers sont faits
pour être travaillés utilisé d'une
manière proportionnée et une manières
aux contrôles et vous avez de nombreux
fichiers qui sont utilisés d'ailleurs ce
qui est assez surprenant en france c'est
que dès qu'on parle de fichiers de
police on se soulève contre ce phénomène
là alors que nous sommes fichier des
centaines de fois en france les banques
les centres commerciaux les réseaux
sociaux une fiche de tout les côtés et
la personne réagit aussi aussi fortement
c'est ça qui est surprenant mais vous
avez entendu cet avocat tout à l'heure
que vient voir l'appartenance syndicale
les habitudes de vie avec effectivement
la sûreté de l'état
oui alors effectivement mais ça c'est
déjà d'actualité
je veux dire aujourd'hui par rapport à
ce texte par rapport à cette décision où
on a de nombreuses réactions mais mais
jusqu'à preuve du contraire du contraire
on a toujours travaillé justement sur
tout c'est sûr toutes ces thématiques
donc où il est très facile il est très
facile de continuer à travailler
justement sur sur quelque chose de 2
comment dirais-je 2
deux religieux ou de syndicats d'un
syndicalisme sur ce thème c'est vraiment
pas un problème
aujourd'hui on a on a quelque chose de
beaucoup plus carrés jeu parce que mieux
mieux ce sera abordée de manière
beaucoup plus contrôlés et du ce sera à
soutirer propres dans le cadre de notre
travail ce ne doit pas être un problème
doit pas être parano par rapport à cette
décision là vous nous assurez enfin
c'est pas vous évidemment qu'elle est le
faire mais il n'ya pas quand même la
crainte que ces informations qui
relèvent du privé
finalement ce compost sur les réseaux
sociaux on n'a pas forcément envie que
les autorités voilà le con le consigne
ces informations vous pouvez nous les
rentiers qu'elles ne seront pas
utilisées contre nous finalement écouté
je vais vous donner un exemple lorsqu'on
a pu travailler sur certaines fichiers
dans la police pour pour pour remonter
sur les antécédents judiciaires d'une
personne ou suis remonté sur sur le
nombre de véhicules que vous pourriez
posséder il ya une vingtaine d'années
c'était très facile pour les policiers
de détergents et ses fichiers sans
contrôle aujourd'hui à partir du moment
où vous rentrez dans des fichiers de
police immédiatement vous devez
apparaître sur une procédure
donc nous sommes hyper contrôlé nous
pouvons pas sortir des données d'un
fichier sans s'expliquer et se justifier
justement notre travail
donc ça prouve bien qu'on a largement
évolué qu'on est très contrôlée et qu'on
ne peut pas pour des raisons autres que
de la sécurité intérieure ou sûreté
nationale nous pouvons battre à
travailler sur ces fichiers donc il ya
quand même une protection des données
sur ce que nous n'avions pas encore il y
avait en train tanger le système bien là
dessus c'était beaucoup plus facile pour
n'importe quel policier d'accéder un
fichier sans qu'on sache les raisons
pour lesquelles on rentrait dans ses
fichiers or aujourd'hui ce n'est plus le
cas donc je peux vous donner avec mon
expérience une garantie c'est que
nous travaillons pour la sécurité
intérieure certainement pas pour
alimenter d'autres sources en tout cas
administratives ou autres
par exemple combien qu'on comprenne est
ce que la police va se servir de ces
renseignements de ce fichier avant une
manifestation on se souvient évidemment
des manifestations le samedi dès gilet
jaune est ce que ces personnes seront
justement ficher la police va les
regarder un petit peu les profils des
personnes entre guillemets dits à risque
pour l île à partir du moment où il ya
un risque pour justement pour la
sécurité intérieure nous travaillerons
mais nous n'allons pas photographier
tous les manifestants de dents lors d'un
rassemblement pour les identifier et
hypothétiquement les cibles et comme d d
d extrémistes ce n'est pas du tout seul
but de ces fichiers c'est de pouvoir
justement aller plus vite et il ne pas
se tromper de cible
ce sera un outil il faut savoir que
voilà ces fichiers restaurants ce sont
des outils se sont pas sots pe qui
seront à la manoeuvre se sont biens ou
les policiers qui travailleront avec
avec ces outils pour identifier les
fauteurs de troubles mais voilà il faut
savoir ce qu'on veut juste vous savez
vous me prenez l'exemple d'une
manifestation pour qu'elle soit
préservée pour qu'elle soit sécurisée
il faut écarter les fouteurs de trouble
c'est le but de deux de ces outils là
c'est de pouvoir faire la différence
entre les voiles ou les casseurs les
extrémistes et les manifestants
aujourd'hui clairement cet élargissement
c'est un vrai atout pour la police ça va
changer votre travail dans le bon sens
ou en tant que policier
disons que réglementairement ou oui ça
tout cela cesse c'est un atout
supplémentaire mais nous avions déjà un
autre possession ces outils pour
travailler c'est pour cette raison que
il n'y a aucune raison de s'inquiéter
aujourd'hui par rapport à un texte qui
qui a été qui a été finalement
accepter aujourd'hui sur ce thème il n'y
a aucune raison de s'inquiéter puisque
depuis depuis de nombreuses années nous
travaillons avec ces outils là et ça a
toujours été un atout à partir du moment
où de sécuriser justement notre entre
notre nation notre notre population
c'est aux matières que sur un plan légal
on est encore plus q comment dirais-je
web beaucoup plus dans les clous et on a
des comptes à rendre à partie quand on
utilise de ces fichiers et on sera
encore plus des réseaux dans une
procédure pour pour faire ressortir ce
qu'on doit retenir c'est à dire ciblé
identifier ceux qui peuvent justement
semer le trouble sur notre territoire et
quand je dis semer le trouble s'est pas
seulement sur des sur des idées sur des
idées bien précises des précisent ces
sujets qui peuvent aller très loin dans
le trouble et et porter une nuisance une
atteinte à la liberté des uns et des
autres c'est ça qui est important
merci beaucoup et bruno bartocetti
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur ert
france merci à vous et direction présent
les états unis avec le double la double
élection sénatoriale qui se tient
aujourd'hui dans l'état de géorgie les
résultats du scrutin auront un impact
décisif sur le début du mandat du
président élu joe biden et donald trump
lui aussi ont donc tenu à se rendre hier
en géorgie pour soutenir leur candidat
des explications avec mathilde romagne
une journée aux allures de campagne
présidentielle en géorgie ce mardi une
double élections sénatoriales cruciales
s'y déroulent
donald trump et joe biden se rendent sur
place pour soutenir leurs candidats
respectifs au sénat vous voterez pour
john o sauf et raphael warnock vous en
verrez deux sénateurs qui se battront
pour vous en ce moment à vous avez deux
sénateurs qui pensent qu'il ne travaille
pas pour vous il travaille pour trump et
je suis sérieux pensez-y à vous avez
deux sénateurs qui pensent que leur
loyauté est envers trump pas envers la
géorgie vous avez deux sénateurs qui
pensent avoir prêté serment à donald
trump
bah la constitution des états unis les
démocrates essaye de voler la maison
blanche vous ne pouvez pas les laisser
faire vous ne pouvez pas les laisser
voler le sénat vous ne pouvez pas
laisser faire vous ne pouvez pas laisser
faire si vous n'allez pas voter les
socialistes les marxistes dirigeront
notre pays si vous ne donnez pas tout ce
que vous avez pour sauver votre pays
vous n'aurez plus de pays baltes et
l'arc
l'enjeu est de taille si les deux
candidats démocrates sont élus
démocrates et républicains auront alors
50 sièges chacun au sénat ce sera à la
future vice-présidente kamala harris de
départager les votes et donc de faire
pencher la balance du côté de son parti
dans le même temps donald trump refuse
toujours de reconnaître la victoire de
son adversaire à la présidentielle
selon les révélations du washington post
le président sortant aurait appelé le
secrétaire d'état de géorgie pour lui
demander de trouver des votes en sa
faveur
un élu républicain qui confirment la
défaite et de trump dans cet état il est
assez clair qu'il n'a malheureusement
pas gagné je dis cela en tant que
républicain mais en tant que secrétaire
d'état je peux dire avec certitude que
le président trump n'a pas gagné l'état
de géorgie je ne prends pas vraiment de
décision ce que je fais c'est suivre la
loi et suivre les faits les chiffres
sont les chiffres et les chiffres que
nous avons communiqué sont actuellement
correctes
l'obstination du président sortant a nié
sa défaite va-t-elle jouer en sa
défaveur
en tout cas sur le papier en géorgie les
républicains partent favoris cet état
n'a pas élu de démocrates au sénat
depuis 20 ans et pour en parler nous
sommes avec françois durpaire historien
spécialiste des états unis bonsoir en
soit dur père merci d'être avec nous
évidemment scrutin décisif 1 qui se
tient aujourd'hui aux états unis qui
doit donc décider de la majorité au
sénat
élection majeure pour l'avenir du pays
oui il ya en fait trois enjeux le
premier enjeu c'est l'agenda législatif
de joe biden si le sénat et républicains
à bien vous imaginez bien que en matière
d'écologie en matière de justice sociale
en matière économique la politique de
joe biden ne sera pas la même
il sera en cohabitation la deuxième
chose c'est très immédiat c'est la
domination au cabinet pour nommer son
cabinet son ministère à bien il faut
avoir la validation du sénat
et rappelez-vous que mitch mcconnell qui
était le chef des républicains au sénat
et bien avait donné du fil à retordre à
barack obama il avait fallu onze mois
onze mois de blocage donc pour la
nomination du cabinet et puis il ya un
troisième enjeu qui est ça on va suivre
ça avec beaucoup d'attention
c'est le degré de confiance du peuple
américain à l'égard de sa démocratie
léger revient vont-ils voter vont-ils
voter dans ce contexte où on leur dit
les élections sont truquées l'élection
présidentielle était truqué cette
élection on peut vous la voler 68% des
républicains sont d'accord avec donald
trump pour dire cette élection
présidentielle a été volé donc voilà ce
sont les trois enjeux d'un scrutin qui
vous le voyez beaucoup plus importants
que le simple deuxième tour d'une
élection sénatoriale dans un état
américain
alors c'est vrai que françois durpaire
nous nous sommes habitués à notre
système français où traditionnellement
souvent après l'élection présidentielle
on a tendance à donner la majorité au
parlement au président pour qu'il puisse
mener ses réformes le programme qu'il a
promis pendant sa campagne
aux etats unis ce n'est pas tout à fait
la même chose si on comprend bien ou
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose
parce que la vote dans un deuxième tour
en géorgie c'est la règle parce que
aucun candidat n'a passé le cap des 50%
donc il faut faire un deuxième tour
d'ordinaire lorsqu'il ya un deuxième
tour
c'est plutôt favorable au parti
républicain pourquoi parce que il ya
généralement plus de républicains qui se
mobilisent dans ce type d'élections
locales
mais là il ya quand même que je de très
différent c'est que la géorgie n'a pas
été gagné par 2 1 trinquent
c'est la première fois depuis trente ans
que la charge est gagné par à des boks
et c'est très indécis d'ailleurs tous
les sondages
vous avez entendu les reportages sont
dans la la marge d'erreur léger avantage
aux républicains mais que s'est il passé
depuis novembre est ce que les
républicains vont se déplacer parce que
je vous ai dit soit 100% 68% des
républicains sont d'accord avec donald
trump ça veut dire que tous les autres
ne sont pas nécessairement d'accord avec
donald raté et la nouveauté depuis
quelques semaines c'est que le parti
républicain est divisée on le verra
cette fois après demain on va peut-être
en reparler au congrès pour la
certification de la victoire de joe
biden et bien cette division du parti va
t-elle se retrouver sur le terrain dans
une division des électeurs avec une
partie des électeurs qui ne se
déplacerait pas vous voyez c'est
extrêmement ouvert justement vous
parliez de cette étape n'a pas gagné
donald trump lui en tout cas il continue
à dire le contraire on a vu cette vidéo
publiée par le washington post qui a
fait beaucoup parler de notre homme
accusé de faire pression sur le
secrétaire d'état de géorgie pour qu'ils
lui trouvent entre guillemets ces
fameuses 12000 voit comment réagit sur
ce point le camp républicain cette
attitude de donald trump
alors ce qui est très intéressant c'est
de voir effectivement ce qu'en pense
notamment les sénateurs et les
représentants républicains parce que
après demain mercredi
ils vont devoir se prononcer c'est la
deuxième date importante de la semaine
américaine le 5 dont l'élection aux
jours j ai le 6 la certification des
votes par le sénat et vous savez qu'il
ya treize sénateurs d'accord avec donald
trump pour dire cette élection a été
truquée nous allons contester ces
sénateurs se retrouvent autour de tes
cruz le sénateur bien connu du texas et
de josh hall et mais il y à des
républicains qui ne sont pas d'accord et
il ya déjà 21 sénateurs républicains qui
ont dit à nous on s'opposera absolument
à cette tentative
nous voterons la certification pour
autre show my dad
un sénateur celui d'oklahoma qui dit
bien si je ne devais pas certifiées bio
maiden ce serait en quelque sorte violer
son serment de deux sénateurs donc on
peut s'attendre mercredi à a2 b1
finalement à des oppositions à
l'intérieur du parti républicain
pression du président des états unis
mais vous voyez qu'une partie les
républicains et même majoritaire pour
l'instant et bien et au stella la
tentative de non certification des votes
ça laisse présager de ce qui se passera
après on a dit que denain trappe était
quelqu'un qui avait une grosse influence
chez les conservateurs parce qu'il a
fait un score très important à plus de
soixante dix millions de voix mais vous
voyez que lorsque donald trump et est en
passe de partir et bien déjà au sein du
parti républicain il ya une partie des
voix et bien qu'ils s'expriment pour
dire il faut tourner la page
justement françois à quoi doit-on
s'attendre pour la suite concernant
donald trump parce que on voit il
poursuit évidemment une stratégie
le président américain sortant on pense
on a souvent dit déjà à 2024 selon vous
oui on ya beaucoup de raisons qui font
que donald trump veut rester au coeur de
l'actualité et il ya quand même quelque
chose à dire c'est que avant que donald
trump le choix candidat victorieux
il a été candidat quatre choix en tout
cas il a laissé entendre qu'ils seraient
candidats quatre fois l'élection
présidentielle dire que l'élection
présidentielle dans la vie de donald
trump a compté y compris dans ses
affaires pour rester au coeur de cette
actualité
alors là il va pas sortir de l'actualité
il a plus d'abonnés twitter par exemple
que le président américain élu joe biden
alors c'est pas anecdotique un twitter
c'est pas juste pour s'amuser c'est de
la communication politique
chacun des messages de donald trump sera
re tweeté à des dizaines de milliers à
des centaines de milliers parfois de
bien de supporter qui continueront à le
soutenir
2024 de tête mais avant 2024
quel va être l'impact
toute politique de dun trucks avait
einsenhower disait un homme politique il
tient sa force dans le fait qu'un grand
nombre de citoyens le crois et beaucoup
de citoyens américains croient donald
trump la moitié du peuple américain et
plus même crois que c'est un menteur
mais l'autre moitié du peuple américain
pense que c'est le seul à dire la vérité
en tout cas on l'aura compris
donald trump laisse le pays dans un état
plutôt divisée vous venez encore de de
le rappeler enrique et à riom le leader
d'époque bon les airs une milice
d'extrême droite fidèles à donald trump
a été arrêté son arrestation qui
survient donc alors que deux journées de
mobilisation en faveur de trames sont
prévues à washington et on doit
s'attendre aux états unis à une montée
des tensions ces prochains mois alors on
a vu déjà des tensions s'exprimer y
compris dans la rue au cours des
dernières semaines entre partisans de
donald trump et adversaires de la trappe
ces tensions n'ont pas débouché sur deux
de détention extrêmement grave
on n'a pas eu à déplorer dans tout le
pays
des oppositions vraiment très massives
on peut penser qu'avec l'arrivée de joe
biden finalement la politique américaine
reprenne son cours
ce pays c'est un éternel recommencement
de désir de volonté et d'efforts
d'unités ils s'appellent les états unis
d'amérique
donc il faut peut-être faire confiance
dans cette démocratie américaine est
peut-être que la nouveauté c'est celle
dont on parlait il ya quelques secondes
c'est ce rapport à la vérité la division
il y en a toujours eu il ya eu des
guerres culturelles dans l'histoire
américaine
pensez aux années 60 c'est pas nouveau
la division du peuple américain mais en
pro revanche sur cette question de la
vérité certains croient certains médias
d'autres ont d'autres médias ou se
penchent simplement sur les réseaux
sociaux
les théories du complot sont de plus en
plus partagée et on le voit notamment on
n'a pas parlé ce soir du coronavirus
mais c'est vraiment la grande
faire aujourd'hui aux états unis avec
des ralentissements notamment beaucoup
d'américains qui se disent on ne va pas
assez vite dans la vaccination la
campagne de vaccination et d'autres
américains qui disent dans ce vaccin est
très très mauvais et négatif
donc c'est vraiment la grande question
peut-être de ce début de xxième siècle
aux états unis la question de la
postérité
merci françois défaire pour votre
analyse merci d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur arte france dans le reste de
l'actualité et miro qui vient
d'officialiser l'enrichissement de
l'uranium à hauteur de 20 % ce matin une
production bien au-delà du seuil prévu
par l'accord international de vienne
sceller en 2015
l'union européenne régie assure vouloir
redoubler d'efforts pour préserver cet
accord les détails avec air robin plus
elle est médiatique et shi c'est une
annonce qui ne passe pas pour la
communauté internationale en relançant
la production d'uranium enrichi à 20%
l'iran s'est affranchi des restrictions
imposées par le traité de vienne
avec cette nouvelle procédure or téhéran
se désengage un peu plus de cet accord
une décision désapprouvée par l'union
européenne et israël
si cette annonce des autorités
iraniennes et mise en oeuvre elle
constituerait une entorse considérable
vis-à-vis des engagements nucléaires de
l'iran dans le cadre de l'accord de
vienne
c'est une violation flagrante et au
talent de ses engagements
sb il n'y a pas d'autre explication que
l'intention de l'iran de poursuivre la
fabrication d'armes nucléaires
bienvenue je le répète israël ne
permettra pas à l'iran de fabriquer des
armes nucléaires tu me chagrine eu les
discussions autour du nucléaire iranien
se sont encore tendues en novembre
dernier après l'assassinât du principal
responsable scientifique du programme
nucléaire iranien
selon téhéran cet attaque aurait été
mise en oeuvre par israël en réponse le
parlement a adopté une loi préconisant
de produire de stocker au moins 120 kg
d'uranium enrichi à 20 % chaque année
samedi dernier les responsables de
l'organisation de l'énergie atomique ont
confirmé être prêt à lancer la nouvelle
procédure d'enrichissement
c'est le président qui devrait donner
les directives sur cette question son
premier ordre préliminaire a été
d'envoyer une lettre à l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie atomique ce
que nous avons fait nous sommes telles
des soldats et nos doigts sont sur les
gâchettes le commandant doit commander
et nous nous tirons nous sommes prêts
pour cela et nous allons produire de
l'uranium enrichi à 20% dès que possible
de son côté la diplomatie américaine
qualifie la décision iranienne de
chantage
l'enrichissement d'uranium à 20% par
l'iran à fordo est une tentative claire
d'accentuer sa campagne de chantage
nucléaire
une tentative qui continuera d'échouer
dans ce contexte l'entrée en fonction de
joe biden à la maison blanche semble de
plus en plus urgente pour la question du
nucléaire iranien le président américain
élu souhaite préserver l'accord de
vienne mise à mal depuis que son
prédécesseur en a retiré les états unis
en mai 2018
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur la stratégie
française face à la pandémie confinement
ouvre ce vaccin le gouvernement d'avis
qu'il a vu ce sera l'objet de notre face
à face et puis direction le royaume uni
re conflit n'est totalement depuis
aujourd'hui et ce jusqu'au mois de mars
au moins face à l'envolée des quatre co
vide
[Musique]
gfr
vous insistez beaucoup sur l'aspect des
dépenses publiques ce que je critique
c'est que on est dans un état
d'addiction de grande dépendance à la
dépense publique je ne veux pas du sang
et des larmes leçons et lamont les actes
et j'ai trop de dépenses trop d'état je
pense en tout cas qu'il ya trop de
bureaucratie c'est à dire un état
inefficace tout ça a été financée
essentiellement par de la dette
le problème est moins la dette en
réalité moi je pense qu'on remboursera
la dette par la croissance donc il faut
essayer de libérer l'économie française
et notamment le travail
notre problème en france c'est un
problème où la dépense publique est
excessive
mais surtout elle n'est pas productive
les français n'en ont pas pour leur
argent
de ce point de vue à emmanuel macron n'a
rien changé par exemple par rapport à
son prédécesseur françois hollande
[Musique]
les chinois ne sont pas des guerriers
ce sont avant tout des commerçants ils
ont négocié avec quinze pays
le partenariat régional économie globale
qui crée la plus grande zone de libre
échange du monde l'annnonce de sa
signature par vidéo à hanoi bouleverse
les équilibres mondiaux et consacre la
perte d'influencé américaine dans cette
partie goût il est clair qu'avec cet
accord le pôle économique mondiale tant
au niveau du développement que de
l'interactivité est dorénavant
durablement installé sur le continent
asiatique avec son est puissant tranché
rendez vous compte un espace économique
occupé par 2 milliards 200 millions
d'habitants qui représente 30% de la
production mondiale de riz qu il est
triste et même inquiétant de constater
que l'europe se retrouve aujourd'hui
marginalisée par rapport à l'air super
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
vous êtes l'unique femme en lice pour
cette présidentielle pourquoi vous êtes
candidate
aujourd'hui quand on voit comment vivre
nos populations
on se rend compte que ya une grande
pauvreté qui s'installe doublé de
préoccupations sécuritaires profonde
devant une telle situation je pense
qu'il était nécessaire pour moi d'offrir
une autre voie il ya des groupes armés
qui occupe une bonne partie du pays
les pays amis ont été à nos côtés pour
essayer deux camps semblent les fils et
les filles de la république
centrafricaine puissent s'entendre et
sortir du cycle infernal des conflits
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce mardi 5 janvier vaccins pour les
pompiers les aides à domicile de plus de
50 ans listes d'inscription pour les
volontaires à l'antidote centres de
vaccination après les critiques sur la
lenteur de la campagne vaccinale olivier
veyron accélère la cadence à la veille
d'un nouveau conseil de défense et sous
la pression d'un emmanuel macron en
déplacement à tours si la france vit
sous couvre-feu pour l'instant ses
voisins eux serre la vis confinement au
royaume uni depuis aujourd'hui devenue
inévitable tant la situation sanitaire
se dégrade chaque jour davantage plus de
soixante mille nouvelles contaminations
ce mardi un record en allemagne angela
merkel prolonge l et renforce les
restrictions jusqu'au 31 janvier la
chancelière qui a évoqué aujourd'hui
avec la dîmière poutine l'éventualité
d'une production conjointe de vaccins un
sommet des pays du golfe qui s'ouvre
aujourd'hui sur fond de réconciliation
régionale avec la signature d'un accord
de solidarité et de stabilité
la veille l'arabie saoudite a rouvert
son espace aérien et ses frontières
terrestres et maritimes au qatar et
liens diplomatiques étaient rompues
depuis plus de trois ans entre les deux
pays
[Musique]
la campagne de vaccination française
critiquée pour son extrême lenteur
seulement 500 cette vaccination
officielle jusqu'à présent ce qui pousse
certains maires à vouloir prendre la
main sur ce dossier
si certains d'entre eux saluent la
volonté du gouvernement d'accélérer la
cadence des vaccinations contre locaux
vides
d'autres veulent agir au niveau des
territoires en proposant des centres de
vaccination et des moyens logistiques
c'est le cas de la ville à 10 me dans
l'essonne où l'édile francisque
figure où se porte volontaire pour
ouvrir une salle municipale nous sommes
en direct avec luis bonsoir francis
qu'est vigo merci d'être avec nous vous
êtes président de l'union des maires de
l'essonne maire radicaux centristes dini
vous êtes avec nous vous souhaitez vous
donc l'ouverture de centres de
vaccination dans votre commune
indispensable selon vous aujourd'hui
pour tenter d'accélérer cette cadence
oui au-delà de notre commune ce que l'on
ressent aujourd'hui c'est un double
cafouillages de la part des
administrations en général c'est d'abord
un cafouillage dans l'axé prioritaire
aux soins on a bien vu aujourd'hui
l'accélération du temps jusqu'à présent
la stratégie de l'état depuis décembre
qui bien arrêtées étaient 2 1 signant
éviter le personnel et les personnes
dans les ehpad
aujourd'hui olivier ferrand le ministre
de la santé a élargi les priorités sous
l'effet de la semaine alarme qui a été
tirée par les maires et à sa commande de
deux professionnels en élargissant les
priorités aux personnes de plus de 75
ans en dehors des ehpad
ces visites sont déjà plusieurs millions
personnes qui sont potentiellement
concernés par le vaccin de manière
prioritaire et aujourd'hui on fait ce
que l'on ressent de plus en plus c'est
une forme de crainte de l'état de
revivre à l'envers le fiasco de la crise
vaccinale achat il ya dix ans il ya dix
ans et bien la seconde de sang qui
étaient ouverts sur les territoires en
essonne nous avions 17 centres qui
étaient ouverts qui était à dos à dos et
sociales shs juive au centre hospitalier
et on s'est aperçu finalement vous
regardez d'aussi jeune à l'époque
finalement à autant de gens prévus sont
allés dans les centres de vaccination
pour une maladie qui s'est révélée plus
bénite en tout cas par rapport au corps
et 19 et aujourd'hui le spectre qu'ils
vont nous aussi nous revivrons linverse
l' inverse c'est à dire de ne pas avoir
suffisamment de centres de vaccination
sur l'ensemble des territoires
olivier galland annonce environ si son
centre pour la fin du mois de janvier
sur l'ensemble de la france
ça veut dire oriane aussi centre par
département alors même que l'on va
devoir accélérer la vaccination au
printemps et aujourd'hui ce que l'on dit
nous les élus et les mains
et les départements on n'est pas prêt
donc on demande simplement n'ont pas
forcément de reprendre la main ici l
instant dans vos titres mais simplement
on souhaite participer à la campagne de
vaccination parce que nous sommes tous
dans le même bateau
or on doit tous travailler pour sortir
par le haut de la crise
comment justement est accueilli par le
gouvernement votre démarche est ce que
vous avez l'occasion vous les maires en
tout cas d'avoir un retour justement de
cette proposition dead si on a bien
compris aux autorités alors on a écrit
hier en essonne on a fait une lettre
cosignée avec un président du
département et moi même en tant que
représentant des maires de l'essonne à
emmanuel macron la lettre est partie
hier
nous sommes en relation régulière avec
en essonne le préfet de l'essonne et
lequel nous avons des relations tout à
fait constructive mais aujourd'hui les
réponses sont plutôt poli la réponse
aujourd'hui du préfet de l'essonne c'est
de dire ça avance on s'organise on
entend vos propositions et aujourd'hui
s'arrête là simplement lorsque l'on veut
mettre en place des centres de
vaccination ça prend du temps ça prend
plusieurs semaines certains maires sont
prêts ont réalisé des centres je dirais
un peu témoin comme à poitiers avec mon
collègue karl olive
mais ça s'organise ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui si on veut être prêt en
avril mais province in et plus largement
la population c'est maintenant qu'on te
pose aussi prendre c'est maintenant pour
d'organiser une carte spatiale de ses
futurs centres et ne pas attendre
d'abord la campagne prioritaire de
validation telle qu'elle se met en place
et on s'accélère depuis quelques heures
clairement pour dire qu'on comprenne
aujourd'hui comment ça se passe
concrètement dans votre commune olivier
ferrand a dit avec serrer la la cadence
comment ça se passe où sont par exemple
les doses de vaccins avant d'être
acheminés dans l'est dans les hôpitaux
alors aujourd'hui en fait on a eu la
course cet après-midi en interne d'avoir
par exemple sur le département de
l'essonne
trois centres de vaccination seront
stockés ont proposé les vaccins de son
troisième chu à longjumeau evry et tente
dans le sud de l'essonne
le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui on sait
qu'on a un sujet logistique de
conservation du vaccin avec l'esprit bio
une solution adaptée mais encore une
fois on n'a qu'une partie des
informations est ce que l'on ressent
finalement si une forme de péché
d'orgueil de l'administration et de
l'état qui consiste à tracer sa route
dans ses stratégies vaccinales
d'entrendre poliment les propositions et
des collectivités nous on sait au
concept m en mettre en place des lieux
on l'a montré il ya dix ans les
collectivités dans rentrée avec toute
une chaîne logistique
en revanche on sait que l'état sont
aussi de cesser de vacciner est ce que
l'on regrette simplement c'est de ne pas
être dans une relation totalement
transparents on ne voit pas ce que
craint l'état et l'administration de
travailler main dans la main des
territoires francesca vidéo ma prochaine
question se souvient de jean castex
fraîchement élu qui nous parlait de
décentralisation avec son accent
chantant du sud comment vous expliquer
cette forme je ne sais pas si on peut
parler de défiance mais voilà de ne pas
finalement faire confiance aux régions
au maire de ne pas déléguer alors que
manifestations on vend il faudrait le
faire et je vais vous dire je pense que
tout simplement on a on a un système qui
est grippé
moi je le vois je suis maire depuis six
ans on a à faire dans nos partenaires
publics
régulièrement et à de grands
professionnels de l'action publique
parmi les fonctionnaires élus différents
types de professionnels
mais je crois que c'est le système qui
est grippé je pense que malheureusement
aujourd'hui on sent que healy à cette
eau de cette tentation qui est presque
culturelle en france d'avoir une
bureaucratie forte très descendante très
très verticale aujourd'hui c'est ce
qu'on dénonce ça va à rebours de
l'histoire
quand on regarde toutes nos les
démocraties nos voisins aujourd'hui le
système est totalement territorialisées
et si on a vu un état efficace et fort
dans ses compétences régaliennes et des
territoires qui ne sont tout autant dans
leurs compétences ça fonctionnerait
bienvenus le problème je pense qu'il est
vraiment structurelles on a affaire à
des personnes qui ce que tu vois tu vas
bien faire mais on a ce problème de
confiance tout simplement entre les
territoires et l'administration
donc on doit définitivement
décentraliser ce pays ne pas le faire
d'une manière en catimini roues à marche
forcée à reculons après il faut
réellement le faire
vous savez moi je suis persuadé que
cette fille sanitaire ça veut dire que
c'est le début du 21e siècle dans nos
livres d'histoire parce qu'on a été au
collège en vicier on disait que le xxème
siècle a démarré après la guerre de
14-18 bien moi je pense que le 21e
siècle démarre avec cette crise
sanitaire
eh bien on doit le démarrer en france
avec une vraie décentralisation
merci beaucoup en tout cas à prendre
puisque vigo rault président de l'union
des maires de l'essonne
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france et cela devait être un rendez
vous quotidien le bilan de la campagne
de vaccination devait être publié chaque
jour à compter d'aujourd'hui
mais cela a pris du retard l'exécutif a
promis d' amplifier la stratégie
vaccinale alors où en sommes nous
quelles sont les dernières annonces sur
le front de la vaccination fait le point
devant le ministère de la santé avec
estelle farges amplifié et accéléré
simplifié ce sont allés nouveau mot
d'ordre de la stratégie vaccinale de la
france contre le coc vide 19 précision
ce matin d'olivier ferrand le ministre
de la santé qui a tenu à afficher la
volonté à du gouvernement d'accélérer la
cadence après avoir essuyé de nombreuses
critiques sur la lenteur de la mise en
place de la campagne de vaccination en
france
olivier ferrand qui a tenté de rassurer
le rythme de croisière du pays va
rejoindre celui de nos voisins européens
ce sont ses mots car la france est à la
traîne sur le nombre de personnes
vaccinées dans le pays
du côté des annonces et bien hier le cap
des 2000 vacciner a été franchie la
liste des personnes éligibles aux
vaccins elle s'élargit à petit à petit
après à les soignants de plus de 50 ans
hier place dans les prochains jours aux
pompiers et aux aides soignants aussi un
de plus de 50 ans avant la fin du mois
de janvier les plus de 75 ans qui ne
résident pas dans des ehpad pourront eux
aussi se faire vacciner et puis sachez
que 5 à 600 centres de vaccination
devraient voir le jour à la fin du mois
jean castex étaient aussi sur le front
un pour défendre la stratégie du
gouvernement depuis toulon où il était
en déplacement le premier ministre a
fustigé est des polémiques stériles qui
n'ont jamais sauvé aucune vie ce sont à
ces mots le premier ministre qui a aussi
indiqué qu'il tiendrait une conférence
de presse aux côtés d'olivier véran
jeudi avant un conseil de défense et un
conseil des ministres qui eux se
dérouleront à mercredi
enfin sachez qu olivier aveyron sera
entendu au sénat le 12 janvier prochain
pour s'expliquer sur les mesures
correctives mises en place par le
gouvernement pour pallier la lenteur de
la france sur le front de la vaccination
et l'accélération de la vaccination
olivier ferrand et donc sur tous les
plateaux de télé de radio pour en être
le vrp ce matin encore sur rtl le
ministre de la santé annonce et 4000
vacciner lundi pourtant le chiffre
officiel reste à 507 personnes
loin donc de l'objectif des 33 miss
vaccinés par jour et du million de
français vaccinés à la fin du mois
hasard du calendrier on parle
d'accélération moment même on soupçonne
une pénurie de vaccins en france après
le ratage des masques et des tests
peut-on encore faire confiance au
gouvernement
c'est l'objet de notre face à face
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
guillaume rosiers vous êtes le fondateur
de kovy tracker sur twitter vous
analysez la remontée quotidienne des
chiffres liés à la vaccination en france
bonsoir à vos côtés joachim mason forget
et député des français établis hors de
france jeunes stein et suisse home vous
êtes basé bonsoir joachim ça ne forge et
merci d'être avec nous alors guillaume
rosiers je me tourne vers vous pour
recommencer parce qu'on attendait avec
beaucoup d'impatience ce chiffre promis
par olivier v moi on s'est pas les
médias qui sont en demande de ce chiffre
c'est le ministre de la santé qui nous
l'a promis le chiffre des vaccinés
est-ce que vous avez des informations
sur ce point parce qu'on les attendait
quand même pour pour ce soir oui on
attendait évidemment avec grande
impatience les chiffres du nombre de
personnes vaccinées
et aujourd'hui j'ai appris du ministère
de la santé que 5000 personnes ont été
vaccinées uniquement sur la journée
d'aujourd'hui et jusqu'à 17 heures arrêt
chiffres ont été arrêtés à 17 heures
donc ils sont probablement d'ores et
déjà plus élevé ça veut dire que plus de
7000 personnes ont été vaccinées depuis
le début de la campagne vaccinale
dimanche dernier donc ça veut dire en
clair qu'on ressent clairement cette
accélération promise par emmanuel macron
joachim sommes forgés c'est sont des
informations qui peuvent être rassurant
tout vous trouvez un petit peu vain
cette litanie qu'on nous promet des
chiffres chaque soir du nombre de
vaccinés mais je déplore cette course à
l'échalote parce que simplement nous ne
sommes pas dans une situation où nous
sommes dont une urgence extrême
les faits sont là la logistique de l'êta
a vraisemblablement failli comme elle
avait failli sur les masques et sur les
thèses de telle sorte que nous ne sommes
pas prioritaires elle sent le vent sur
les premiers vaccins qui sont à
disposition et qui sont sorties qui ont
été administrés massivement royaume uni
en israël dans d'autres pays je vous
précise également que la chine a
commencé avec signer avec ses propres
vaccins depuis longtemps le problème n
est pas ça c'est que vous avez de toute
façon des français qui seront méfiants
ils ont raison de l'être vous avez des
français qui sont pressés peut-être
quand ils raison d'être aussi je ne sais
pas toujours est il que les faits sont
là ils sont tenaces alors ce temps il
devrait être utilisé non pas pour être
dans la croyance pour savoir s'il faut
croire ou novak ça ne s'agit pas d'aller
à la messe ou trois rendus ou ne pas
croire en dieu
il s'agit d'utiliser notre rationalité
on est dans le pays la raison alors
utilisons ce temps parce que ce temps
finalement je pense qu'on l'a on n'est
pas dans une urgence à la journée et on
peut se donner ce temps pour réfléchir
pour avoir un vrai débat scientifique
rationnelle sur les pour et contre de
ces différents vaccins qui je le
rappelle n'utilisent pas tous le même
principe et on peut utiliser ce temps
pour se poser les bonnes questions
notamment par exemple sur la dangerosité
potentielle pas forcément et abîme
pourquoi pas elle peut-être peut-être
existantes sur les ces nouveaux vaccins
arn une nouvelle technologie qui peut
être certes prometteuse mais qui
présente également des risques
guillaume rose y est vous qui est
justement le fondateur de ce comics
tracker vous êtes spécialisé dans ces
chiffres
qu'est ce que vous répondez à joachim
sommes forgés c'est une perte de temps
on n'est pas dans l'urgence qu'il
faudrait plutôt débattre au lieu de
compter alors juste je tenais à répondre
on a on a un stock suffisant de vaccins
pour vacciner plus je m'explique on a
reçu 500 mille doses le 29 décembre on a
reçu 60 milles 2 le 26 décembre et on va
recevoir encore cinq cent mille doses
d'ici demain à priori ou après demain
donc ça voudra dire que d'ici la fin de
semaine on aura en stock 1 million de
doses donc de quoi vacciner à peu près
de 400000 à 500000 personnes donc le
stock fin de les pays d'autres pays
n'ont pas été privilégiés par rapport à
nous on a reçu les commandes qui avaient
été effectués par l'union européenne et
donc si on a pas vacciner plus c'est par
choix plutôt pour logistique c'est par
choix que ce qu'on avait décidé de
vacciner d'abord des ehpad et qui a vu
quelques lenteurs dans les ehpad donc
depuis lundi depuis hier le personnel de
santé et vacciner massivement hier on a
eu trois mille vaccination aujourd'hui
5000 enfin de 2000 vaccination hier cinq
mille aujourd'hui donc ça monte
clairement en puissance
3500 tu es tout petit chiffre
et oui oui mais on n'a que on peut
vacciner que 400 à 500 mille personnages
rappelle que l'objectif est de vacciner
un million de
personnes d'ici à fin janvier
actuellement avec la cadence actuelle on
y sera on y serait pas du tout puisque
avec la cadence actuelle on n'est pas
bons en maths mais met donc à priori ça
va monter en puissance en train de
monter en puissance et ça devrait
continuer dans les prochains jours
d'après le ministre de la santé
alors ça c'est d'après effectivement le
ministre de la santé sous la pression
certainement dû du chef de l'état nous
dit-on en tout cas emmanuel macron a mis
un coup de pression ce week-end
il n'empêche l'opposition est la
critique je vous propose d'écouter le
patron de la région grand est
hier qui parlait de scandale d'état moi
je considère que l'état est pleinement
responsable de la situation actuelle qui
est une situation d'incompréhension
c'est un scandale d'état et jacky msan
chargé c'est une analyse que vous
partagez où les mots sont un peu fort
écoutez elle est alors soit les
politiques font que de la politique moi
je voudrais qu'on soit dans un temps de
la réflexion on est sans nouvelles
technologies médicales c'est à rien et
c'est moi je l'avenir je crois la
science france est intéressant mais
d'habitude quand on développe une
nouvelle méthode quasiment une méthode
de thérapie génique t on pas peur des
mots le bac des vaccins arn on ne
déploie pas sur la population mondiale
entier donc savoir si en france on est
on est la lanterne rouge sont les plus
rapides passer si on trouve que je viens
et 5000 vaccin en une journée c'est
beaucoup c'est pas assez
franchement on n'en a rien à faire moi
ce qui m'intéresse moi ce qui
m'intéresse est de savoir simplement si
on est dans une situation où les
français ont le droit au débat
si les français ou le droit a dit à une
information libre et éclairé combien les
teams et sommes très clairement à
l'heure actuelle que nous concédons pas
eu droit à cette information pourquoi
est ce que au lieu de de faire des
combats de chiffres
des combats de type de bac 5 qui vont
être utilisés on ne va pas sur le sujet
je rappellerai par exemple que le
professeur fisher lui-même qui est le
monsieur vaccin a conduit des essais
thérapie génique dans le cas d'une
maladie qui est un peu particulière qui
est celle d'un enfant atteint d'un
déficit immunitaire sévère
et puis il a conduit ccc avec un certain
succès et mais malheureusement deux
enfants sur 10 ont développé des
leucémies et le professeur michel
allemand lui-même en évidence ce
mécanisme qui est un mécanisme de
mutagénèse interface personnelle
c'est-à-dire dont l'intégration de denat
des étrangers dans un jeu donc il
provoque des complications certaine et
donc prétendre que disons que c'est
anodin de la reine des gens et puis que
c'est à rennes puis sow finalement ce se
recombiner finalement se recombiner avec
avec l'adn de l'autre c'est un petit pas
de penser qu'il ya un fond de vérité
possible c'est à dire que là on est dans
une situation tout être ça n'arrivera
pas peut-être que le risque est minime
on n'est pas un sou de penser qu'un
fragment des reines qui va rencontrer
une de ces enzymes qui sont présents
dans les rétrovirus le qu'on appelle une
transcriptase inverse puisse permettre
d'arriver à leur fabrique à un fragment
laden qui va lui on se doute s'insérer
dans le génome de l'autre on va
peut-être papa s'est amusé j'ai juste
donné un exemple ce type de débat
scientifique en le vulgariser on peut
tout à fait de proposer aux français
aujourd'hui on fait des comptes
d'apothicaire pour savoir si le
gouvernement est trop en avance ou s'il
est trop tard sur sa stratégie vaccinale
je pense qu'on prend les français pour
des imbéciles simplement si vous voulez
prendre les français pour des
des grandes personnes sont des gens
responsables lors donner un consentement
libre et éclairé
on devrait être dans une situation où le
débat ne devrait pas être un débat de
chapelle de croyance ou de non croyance
me devrait être un un débat scientifique
de fond on va éduquer les gens à ces
nouvelles technologies
on va leur donner les pour et contre on
va leur expliquer le niveau de risque
parce que on a besoin de pouvoir
chacun décide et en âme et conscience
dans une balance bénéfices risques si on
doit être citons dont six cet
intéressant ce qu'on nous dit joachim
sommes forgés parce que c'est vrai pour
le rappel ce dernier sondage ifop publié
il ya quelques jours
58% des français qui me veulent toujours
pas se faire vacciner c'est vrai qu'on
déplace le débat sur une guerre de
chiffres combien de vaccination la
france risée du monde
ça vous inspire quoi est ce qu'il ne
faudrait pas effectivement faire
davantage de pédagogie on a oublié
peut-être ce qui inquiète le plus
une bonne partie des français
aujourd'hui oui bien sûr et je tenais à
répondre je veux qu'ils me semble
changer parce que il est émis des doutes
quant au vaccin arn messager moi je ne
suis ni généticien ni médecin donc je ne
parlerais absolument pas avec une
certitude
j'ai quand même l'impression qu'il ya un
consensus de l'ordre d'une très très
large majorité de généticiens de
médecins de scientifiques de biologistes
pour dire que le vaccin arn messager ne
présente aucun danger et que les rênes
messager et détruit très rapidement par
le corps et de façon naturelle un saint
il manque mène naturellement dans le
corps et qu'en aucun cas ça ne peut
modifier l'adn de notre corps je tiens
aussi à rappeler qu aucun effet grave
n'a été reporté à ce jour et que des des
essais en phase iii d'essais cliniques
ont été faits sur trente mille quarante
mille patients c'est ce sont des
chiffres considérables plus élevé que de
nombreuses autres vaccins et qu'à ce
jour aucun effet indésirable grave n'a
été reporté donc voilà je suis un peu
étonné de 2,2 khalid indiqué joachim
sont gorgés après pour en revenir au
sujet évidemment que c'est pas rassurant
qu'une majorité de français soit
réticente au vaccin
je conseille bien sûr à tout le monde de
se renseigner sur ses vaccins
moi personnellement je le fais je lis
des articles scientifiques pour essayer
de comprendre comment font ils
le vaccin je lis les données pour voir
quels sont les effets indésirables
quelques bien sûr que si elles sont
publiées et je me renseigne surtout
auprès des personnes qui savent les
antilles sur la sur les serveurs
habituel sur lequel on trouve de la
science vous non toute information sur
ces vaccins pas du tout ce que vous avez
vu que je n'ai pas vu que je peux pas
librement comme ses concitoyens comme
scientifique c'est pas vrai cette
littérature existe pas toute la
littérature qui a eu par exemple
notamment dans les discussions sur les
traitements
cette littérature police le traitement
surviennent aussi vous l'avez tout sur l
affaire des bas pendant toute la
première période de ce qu un virus sur
les vaccins ces données sont soumis à la
confidentialité dans les laboratoires on
a des données qui sont parcellaires sur
les mécanismes d'action de ce médecin
sous couvert du coup du secret
industriel
donc nous n'avons pas en main les
données je suis désolé on a des données
extrêmement parcellaires
donc je voudrais pas passer un
consentement libre et éclairé et que
vous tournez on n'est pas vu des effets
secondaires on ne fait alors à anoual à
deux mois du début des vaccinations
moi je vous reparle de recombinaison
génétique est ce que vous croyez
sérieusement on observera ça dans un
délai de quelques joueurs de quelques
semaines et je sais pas pour vous mais
dans quelques années dans quelques
dizaines d'années qu'on aura des choses
alors rocher pour le prodej suis pas
pour l'utiliser mais ted
mais ces méthodes pour qu'on les utilise
il fait encore peu d'habitude un nouveau
traitement une nouvelle méthodologie en
utilise pas sur la planète entière et on
ne peut pas de manière hasardeuse de
clans sont des stratégies vaccinales on
décide d'abord euros de l'attelage puis
en soute puis telle tranche tout à
l'autre dans ce cas là je veux dire si
on voulait pragmatique on peut aussi
dire qu'il faudrait des pages autre
bouffée d'oxygène aux gros puisque le
couvert sont plus à risque de faire des
copies de grade et où elles ce sont eux
qui majoritairement se retrouvent
personnes âgées et personnes obèses dans
les animations on ne fait pas parce que
vous vous donnez un petit moment ça peut
être un petit peu problématique de
l'annoncer comme ça et on peut le
comprendre
tout va plutôt si c'était pragmatique
sous on utiliserait ce type 2
deux compères pragmatique pour établir
les priorités vaccinale donc on voit
bien que tout ça est purement politique
et je passe sur les détails la
logistique
à ce moment-là besoin on a besoin de
cabinets étrangers représentés par des
gens non spécialistes de l'eau de
logistique pour faire le travail
logistique à la palmyre la santé donc
c'est ce qui est annoncée d'un canard
enchaîné avec la présence monsieur de
calan pour auprès qui représente des
intérêts de du cabinet mckinsey
on va laisser le mot de la fin gay
montrozier parce que c'est quand même
dans un souci justement de transparence
et de confiance que vous avez monté
votre plateforme d'information c'est
vrai que voilà on peut contester ce
qu'on dit joachim sonne forget mais il
n'empêche que ça répond à une certaine
partie de l'opinion des français qui une
fois de plus fort majorité ne veulent
toujours pas aujourd'hui se faire
vacciner
il est important de fournir aux français
des données claires qu'ils puissent
vérifier ce qu'on leur dit et ça sera le
mot de la fin pour vous guillaume rozier
oui c'est extrêmement important juste
pour répondre à joachim s'en charger si
les personnes en ehpad et les personnes
âgées sont vaccinés en premier c'est
parce que la haute autorité de santé a
décidé de vacciner en premier parce que
un tiers des décès sont observés en
ehpad et que ça représente 1% de la
population donc c'est facile de vacciner
1 % de la population c'est une minorité
et ça fera baisser les des seuils de 1/3
à peu près donc c'est peu c'est pour
cette raison là maintenant je ne
souhaite pas prendre part aux débats
je ne suis pas généticien je ne suis pas
médecin
mon but est uniquement d'analysé des
données de manière le plus jeune le plus
objectif possible et c'est dans cet
optique que j'ai créée kovy tracker est
donc évidemment c'est extrêmement
important d'avoir des données précises
sur la vaccination est en tout cas sur
vaccins trackers sur kobe tracker pu
suivre ces données de façon très précise
puisque aujourd'hui la plupart des
médecins s'accordent sur le fait que le
vaccin est la seule solution pour
arriver à bout de cette épidémie
c'est la seule solution pour atteindre
un niveau d'immunité collectif qui
permettra d'arrêter l'épidémie est donc
je suive ses chiffres de façon très
précise pour voir quelles proportions la
population est vaccinée et surtout dans
quelle tranche d'âge dans quels
départements en france et à quelle
vitesse pour essayer de pour essayer
d'anticiper l'avenir de l'épidémie merci
à tous les deux en tout cas guillaume
rozier
gens qui me sont changés d'avoir été
avec nous pour débattre de cette
vaccination en france et dans le monde
pour vous en tout cas jacques rincon
forget merci à vous restez avec nous
dans quelques instants nous parlerons du
royaume uni qui re confient des de bain
plus de soixante mille nouvelles
contaminations dénombré aujourd'hui un
record puis direction l'arabie saoudite
où les pays arabes du golfe ont signé un
accord de solidarité et de stabilité
[Musique]
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française
c'était après les attentats du 11
septembre et quand on vient vous voir et
qu'on vous dit écoutez vous avez de la
première femme qui allait rentrer dans
ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu que ben voilà c'est fini pour
moi est ce que je sors mon arme
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ceux du mahler
mais quel est le rapport avec la
radiation mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde même si on
n'est pas en appartements ont énervé
donner le sentiment qu'il faut à chaque
fois se battre ils vivent parfois au
bord des routes nationales pas forcément
loin de paris mais toujours loin de ceux
qui les dirigent
moi j'en ai marre qu'on ait passé un
tour de tracteur et cnooc et leur
campagne il faut savoir c'est une vie
différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles bas pourrait t'aider quoi un
peu plus aujourd'hui la france oubliée
c'est montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois 21h38 les bienvenus en direct
sur rt france si vous nous rejoignez le
nombre de cas positifs au strass
qu'ovide 19 continue d'augmenter
outre-manche
boris johnson annoncé hier soir leur
confinement total de l'angleterre au
moins jusqu'à la mi février
elle rejoint ainsi les cosses le pays de
galles et l'irlande du nord qui ont
également décrété des mesures similaires
en cause notamment le nouveau variant du
coc vide beaucoup plus contagieux et
hôpitaux anglais sont surchargées avec
la majorité du pays déjà soumise à des
mesures extrêmes
il est clair que nous devons faire plus
ensemble pour maîtriser ce nouveau
variant pendant le déploiement de nos
vaccins ou en 26 ans cela signifie que
le gouvernement vous demande à nouveau
de rester chez vous oui mais un peu flou
nous devons maintenant faire tout ce que
nous pouvons pour arrêter la propagation
de la maladie des écoles primaires les
écoles secondaires et les universités à
travers l'angleterre doivent passer à
des services à distance à partir de
demain sauf pour les enfants vulnérables
et les enfants des travailleurs des
secteurs clés et au lendemain de cette
allocution de boris johnson les
britanniques aussi entre amertume et
fatalisme
nous avons vraiment essayé de faire tout
ce que nous pouvions pendant le
confinement est à présent nous sommes au
même point qu'il ya six mois
plus vite on fera ça et on respectera
les restrictions plus vite en sera sorti
de là il ya de la lumière au bout du
tunnel aussi nous avons les vaccins bien
sûr
je pense donc qu'il s'agit juste de
gagner du temps de faire les bonnes
choses en attendant et vous savez d'ici
la fin de l'année tout ira bien
et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis londres avec un martin mac ou les
analyses politiques c'est notre rubrique
vu de l'extérieur ce soir bonsoir martin
m'a collé merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france un troisième
confinement viens d'entendre quelques
réactions mitigées des anglais mais on
imagine tout le même autrement je pose
cela doit être un coup de massue c'est
une nouvelle terrible
le premier ministre a dit au pays
toutes les écoles pouvaient ouvrir
directement que la situation n'était pas
si terrible et les internautes un outil
tout le pays et maintenant j'en plus
finement un confinement plus drastiques
coller le but et c'est dans plus d'un
million de personnes ont contracté le
virus les hôpitaux sont submergés
chaque mulhouse les écoles du primaire
et du secondaire seront fermés jusqu'au
15 février
on a adapté on espère que ce jour là on
pourra ré ouvrir les écoles c'est en
tout cas ce que le gouvernement espère
il espère que d'ici au 15 mars qu à sion
sera meilleur et que les écoles pourront
goûter hierro cela a causé beaucoup de
problèmes pour les parents notamment les
parents qui travaillent qui va s'occuper
des enfants
une fois de plus cela renforce les
inégalités entre les élèves de foyers
plus riches et de foyers plus pauvres à
bruchsal parce que les
ça lui est aisé lorsqu'elle met en place
un apprentissage à distance passe à 35
minutes de plus par jour sur le travail
scolaire que les familles pauvres pour
enfin les moins fortunés on se créeront
donc plus cela va accroître les
inégalités est un problème majeur
le gouvernement espère qu'ils pourront
tester des étudiants les enfants afin de
savoir qui a les forêts soient ou pas
mais le statisticien jeunes incultes on
dit que le test elles ne sont pas très
précis et on pourrait donc tirent
certains élèves qui n'ont pas le virus
alors qu'en fait ils sont contagieux
news le gouvernement essaye de faire en
sorte que nos présidents de personnes le
15 millions de personnes ne soient
vaccinés d'ici à six semaines ton et les
professeurs c'est très important pour
les écoles du bac le but est que tous
les personnels enseignants soient
vaccinés afin qu'il n'y ait plus de
transmission du virus sur les étudiants
attendant 60000 contaminés aujourd'hui
c'est un record pour le royaume uni
on imagine que c'est un terrible aveu
d'impuissance
aujourd'hui de la part du gouvernement
qui vous nous disiez très bien a fait
volte face finalement en quelques jours
cela doit être extrêmement anxiogène
de sentir que les autorités ne peuvent
plus rien entre ce virus y inciter le
gouvernement à accepter le fait que ce
virus est incontrôlable c'est ainsi par
exemple c'est une mutation du virus
calvaire que ces mesures de contrôle et
la seule riposte c'est la vaccination je
donne le beau rôle à la population soit
émue évoluent et 65 millions de
personnes
comment vaccinés 5,5 millions de
personnes ce n'est pas possible
prioriser et que certaines personnes les
personnes de plus de 60 ans par exemple
qui sont prioritaires mais des
personnels des hôpitaux les infirmiers
les docteurs sont aussi nos priorités
doivent être testés et vacciner d'abord
et ensuite comment décider viendra
ensuite les personnes âgées ou les
jeunes les jeunes tease nous devrions
être vaccinés car ensuite nous pourrons
retourner à l'école c'est vraiment un
très gros problème pour le gouvernement
comment décider qui ira d'abord des
chevaux comme ténue donc c'est vraiment
un sujet de polémique qui n'est pas près
de s'éteindre et qui semble insoluble
martin mc cauley pardonnez moi de vous
couper mais d'autant que le deuxième
problème qui se pose c'est au royaume
uni comme ça va venir évidemment en
france c'est déjà le cas en allemagne à
la question du manque de doses
deux vaccins d'ailleurs le royaume uni a
fait un pari audacieux sur ce point il a
décidé de retarder l'injection de la
deuxième dose ce qui n'est pas
recommandé par le fabriquant un phaser
comment accueille cet initié comment les
non pardon les anglais accueillent cette
initiative de la part de boris johnson
qui est quand même assez surprenante en
tout cas audacieuse va prendre bientôt
ce fait la halle car cela les protégera
ceux qui n'ont pas été vaccinées du tout
préféré recevoir une dose donc c'est
encore une fois une question de priorité
à qui doit-on la priorité qui parce que
d'abord qui passe ensuite en troisième
voire en quatrième place
donc c'est un conflit avant et c'est un
véritable dilemme
la plupart des gens acceptent l'idée que
le personnel sanitaire les personnels
des hôpitaux ou des maisons de retraite
doivent passer en premier mais ensuite
il ya les enseignants si on ne vaccine
pas les anciens mais on ne peut pas
rouvrir les écoles de manière
parfaitement sécuritaire donc la seule
solution c'est plus de vaccins a
distribué plus rapidement qu'en mais
comment les répartir dans le pays très
rapidement quand on ne peut pas
simplement les mettre dans un camion et
les envoyer là où on veut il y à un
système logistique a gardé en finition
besoin d'une certaine température et je
pense que l'armée serait la meilleure
solution car c'est une administration
extrêmement efficace de transporter le
vaccin dans le pays de manière très
rapide et efficace serbie lors que le
plomb pourraient accélérer le processus
et tout le monde espère qu on ne va pas
se retrouver face à une véritable
pénurie
cependant cette inévitable et acer
noah il n'y aura plus de vaccins il
faudra donc obtenir de nouveaux vaccins
quelque part garde donc c'est vraiment
n'importe quel chinois pour le
gouvernement très difficile à résoudre
la seule chose qu'on puisse faire le
premier ministre s'est demandé à sa
population d'être raisonnable de garder
son sang-froid jeu deux jours de donner
la priorité à ceux qui a joué qui sont
des professionnels de la santé aux
enseignants et au personnel de maison de
retraite et ensuite ce sera au tour des
jeunes personnes qui elle demande à être
vaccinés immédiatement pouvoir par
exemple retourner à l'école de rugby
merci beaucoup martin à macau les
analyses politiques d'avoir été avec
nous pour vu de l'extérieur ce soir et
outre-rhin le ton monte cité en exemple
pour sa gestion de la crise sanitaire
lors de la première vague en avril
dernier l'allemagne fait face elle aussi
désormais une flambée de nouveau 15 sur
son territoire le gouvernement allemand
se trouve sous pression et annoncé
aujourd'hui la prolongation des mesures
contre la propagation du virus déjà en
place depuis le 16 décembre et précision
de quentin mauclair la deuxième vague de
kovy 19 ne cesse de faire des dégâts en
allemagne et oblige le gouvernement à
réagir après une réunion virtuelle avec
les 16 länder les états régions allemand
la chancelière angela merkel a annoncé
la prolongation des restrictions
jusqu'au 31 janvier prochain
ea nous sommes maintenant dans des
situations critiques dans certains
hôpitaux
ce qui signifie que cela nous a
également incité à adopter des décisions
de grande envergure aujourd'hui ce
travail ne le show se fasse mme le 29
décembre
l'allemagne a recensé plus de 1000 morts
en 24 heures pour la première fois
depuis le début de la pandémie dans
certaines régions la situation est
critique comme en saxe où le taux
d'incidence de la maladie était de 323
ce lundi dans les länder les plus
touchés les déplacements seront
fortement limitées
la creuse nous avons décidé de prendre
des mesures supplémentaires dans les
régions comptant plus de 200 nouvelles
infections pour cent mille habitants
elles doivent limiter le rayon de
circulation à 15 kilomètres autour du
lieu de résidence à moins qu'il n'y ait
une raison valable tigre une folie tous
les commerces sauf les magasins
d'alimentation et les pharmacies
resteront rideau baissé lors des
prochaines semaines
il en va de même pour les écoles les
parcs ainsi que les lieux culturels qui
ne pourront ouvrir comme prévu le 10
janvier cette extension des contraintes
n'est pas forcément très bien accueillie
au sein de la population allemande
il n'ya pas non plus de perspectives et
nous en avons réellement besoin de toute
urgence au moment de savoir comment les
choses vont continuer en général à un
moment donné voilà ce qu'il me manque
il faut dire clairement aujourd'hui et
maintenant que l'espoir que nous avions
lors de la rentrée scolaire que ce
serait une année scolaire plus normal
qu'il serait possible de combler les
retards pris durant l'année scolaire
précédente avec les élèves et pour
enseigner le nouveau programme et pour
mener des examens dans une certaine
mesure
bien sûr cet espoir s'estompe à mesure
que la deuxième vague se prolonge et que
le confinement se poursuite lors de ses
voeux de fin d'année angela merkel avait
annoncé je cite des temps difficiles
pour l'année 2000 21
la deuxième vague de kovy 2009 semble
loin de toucher à sa fin sur le sol
allemand et autres vaccins celui d'une
éventuelle alliance russo allemand en
entretien téléphonique à ce sujet
récemment entre la demir poutine et un
gala merkel la correspondance à moscou
d'antoine frérot
les deux dirigeants se sont souhaité la
bonne année comme le veulent les usages
diplomatiques
le communiqué publié par le kremlin nous
informe qu'il a ensuite été question
d'une possible production conjointe de
vaccins le dialogue devant maintenant
continuer au niveau des ministères de la
santé et autres organismes concernés
alors bien sûr tout cela reste encore
très vague
les contours de cette coopération reste
en effet toujours à définir
à l'heure actuelle la campagne de
vaccination à l'aide du spoutnik v a
démarré en russie depuis le 5 décembre
mais des lots ont aussi été envoyées en
biélorussie en serbie et même en
argentine
l'algérie le brésil ou encore la guinée
devraient leur emboîter le pas la
hongrie elle reçu six mille doses du
spoutnik vais au mois de novembre mais
devraient se détourner de lui
craignant les capacités de production
limitées du vaccin russe et c'est
peut-être en 5e cette coopération russo
allemande pourrait être bénéfique
ce ne serait de toute façon pas la
première collaboration entre la russie
et l'europe
en effet le 11 décembre le laboratoire
suédois britannique astrazeneca et
moscou ont annoncé leur volonté de
combiner leurs deux axes
et c'est sans doute de cette façon par
la mise en commun et la combinaison de
tous ces savoir-faire que l'on pourra
efficacement lutter contre cette
pandémie mais on en parlait tout à
l'heure lors de notre vue de l'extérieur
cette deuxième injection du vaccin
kaiser bio ntech qui peut être retardée
dans certains cas ah non ce soir de l'om
et certains pays européens ont déjà
décidé d'espacé de plus de trois
semaines injection des deux doses malgré
les recommandations des laboratoires en
cause la crainte de ne pas pouvoir
vacciner tout le monde
un approvisionnement qui inquiète
également en france les explications de
solenn gaudin six semaines ou danemark
jusqu'à 12 au royaume uni ce sont les
délais entre la première injection et le
rappel du vaccin de pfizer bio and take
contre le corona virus fixés par ces
deux primes
loin des recommandations des
laboratoires qui prescrivent d'espacer
les deux doses de trois semaines maximum
même si des données démontrent qu'il
existe une protection partielle des
douze jours après la première dose
il n'y a pas de données qui démontrent
que la protection reste en place au-delà
de 21 jours d'autres pays envisagent de
dépasser cette échéance
le gouvernement allemand a demandé aux
autorités sanitaires d'évaluer les
possibilités mais alors pourquoi
repousser l'injection du rappel du
vaccin
le danemark et le royaume-uni craignent
une pénurie et volt administrés au moins
une dose au plus grand nombre de
personnes possible on peut facilement
attendre jusqu'à six semaines
de cette manière nous pourrons vacciner
plus de monde dès maintenant
une pénurie qui inquiète aussi en france
où la campagne de vaccination connaît un
démarrage poussif l'opposition multiplie
les questions je veux que le
gouvernement nous dise la vérité
combien de doses ont été commandées
exactement par la france
j'ai ce désagréable senti
donc il y à une pénurie de vaccins un
manque de commandes
il faut dire la vérité où sont les doses
aujourd'hui le gouvernement nous dit il
y a cinq cent mille doses qui ont déjà
été livrés et 500 mille nouvelles qui
arrivent demain ça veut dire qu'il ya
dans les congélateurs depuis maintenant
plusieurs jours voire plusieurs semaines
des centaines de milliers de doses qui
sont utilisés à rien c'est une immense
perte de chance on trompe les français
en faisant la confusion entre dos des
vaccins des doutes donc sur les raisons
du retard pris par la france dans son
calendrier vaccinal
face à ces critiques le ministre de la
santé promet une accélération des
commandes ce mardi je vais amplifier les
commandes au niveau européen de vaccins
pour pouvoir augmenter le rythme et
l'intensité de livraison des dotations
pour la france et pour l'europe
en france la campagne de vaccination a
officiellement démarré le 27 décembre
dernier
les premiers patients devraient recevoir
leur dose de rappel dans onze jours
selon les indications de pfizer diohine
tech mais à ce stade seulement un peu
plus de 2000 personnes ont été vaccinées
selon le ministre de la santé
faute de stocks ou non le rythme des
vaccinations en france risquent de
compromettre l'efficacité vaccinale
[Applaudissements]
le qatar sort de son isolement dans le
golfe l'arabie saoudite le bahreïn les
émirats arabes unis et l'egypte annonce
le rétablissement de leurs relations
diplomatiques avec doha lors d'un sommet
du conseil de coopération du golfe un
accord de réconciliation a été signée le
contenu du texte n'a pas dé été dévoilé
mais il met fin à plus de trois mois de
forte tension diplomatique entre le
qatar et ses voisins françois xavier
lambert c'est une visite qui symbolise
ce rapprochement entre le qatar et
l'arabie saoudite l'émir de doha est
chaleureusement accueilli par le prince
héritier saoudien mohamed ben salman à
el oula tamim al-thani participe à son
premier sommet du conseil de coopération
du golfe depuis juin 2010 cette date à
laquelle l'arabie saoudite les émirats
bahreïn et l'egypte ont rompu leurs
relations diplomatiques avec doha en
cause notamment son soutien supposé à
des groupes djihadistes ainsi qu'une
trop grande proximité avec l'iran
sous les yeux de jared kushner gendrey
conseiller du président américain
sortant mohamed ben salman annonce la
signature d'un accord de solidarité et
de stabilité
les efforts du coa et est des états unis
nous ont aidés à obtenir un accord où
nous affirmons notre solidarité et la
stabilité du golfe et des pays arabes et
musulmans réajustant les relations
amicales entre nos pays afin de servir
les intérêts de nos peuples
conséquence concrète de cet accord le
rétablissement total des relations entre
le qatar et les quatre pays qui le
boycotter l'arabie saoudite bahreïn
l'egypte et les émirats vont ainsi
rouvrir leurs frontières terrestres
aériennes et maritimes au qatari qui
pourront les franchir librement
il a été décidé aujourd'hui grâce à la
sagesse des dirigeants du golfe et de
l'egypte de tourner la page et de
rétablir toutes les relations
diplomatiques avec le qatar ainsi que
tout ce qui sert des relations entre les
pays membres du conseil de coopération
de l'egypte nous espérons que ce sera
une étape importante vers l'avenir et la
stabilité de la région
reste désormais à savoir si cette
réconciliation pourra durer les quatre
pays avaient formulé 13 condition à la
reprise des relations avec le qatar
notamment la fermeture de la chaîne al
jazeera ou des engagements sur la fin du
financement supposé de groupes
extrémistes doha ne s'est plié à aucune
de ces exigences et pour en parler nous
sommes avec georges malbrunot grand
reporter au figaro spécialiste du
moyen-orient bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france 3 ans et
demi ans de brouille
à quoi peut-on attribuer ce retour en
grâce du qatar quelles sont les raisons
font en fait depuis les gens moins deux
ans si vous voulez l'arabie saoudite et
les émirats arabes unis avait réalisé
que le qatar avait finalement remporté 7
7 cette guerre qui lui avait été imposée
leucate a réussi à contourner le blocus
qui lui était imposé en se rapprochant
la turquie et de l'iran alors que
c'était le but exactement opposé à ce
qu'il t'est recher che à riyad et abu
dhabi
et puis il y a eu la proximité avec les
élections américaines qui ont fait que
l'arabie saoudite
mohammed bin salman le prince héritier a
d'une certaine manière voulu faire
plaisir à joe biden qui n'est pas n'a
pas été comme vous le savez sont son
candidat pour la présidence américaine
que maiden qui voudraient faire pression
sur l'arabie saoudite en matière de
droits de l'homme et là par conséquent
mohammed bin salman lui offre une
possibilité justement de voir une crise
entre alliés des américains réglait
avant même son arrivée à la maison
blanche donc c'est tout ça qui a eu
compte et c'est à la fois le réalisme je
dirais un peu poussé contre 1 qui a
poussé ryad à se rapprocher du qatar ce
comme ça a été dit dans votre reportage
vient d'en qatar est le grand gagnant de
cette percée diplomatique parce que
effectivement ils n'ont pratiquement pas
c'est l'ère van ne connais pas le détail
mais on peut imaginer quand même que le
qatar n'a pratiquement pas céder la fête
al jazeera va rester toujours une chaîne
de télévision qui de temps à autre va
servir de poil à gratter pour le pour le
qatar le qatar va garder sa relation
stratégique avec la turquie
au grand dam de l'arabie saoudite et les
émirats arabes unis le qatar ne servira
pas non plus de rampe de lancement ou
une attaque américaine contre l'iran
donc effectivement l'arabie saoudite ne
dirais pas réaliste aux contraintes
s'est dit c'est le moment de un petit
peu de ne tourner la page et d'amorcer
cette réconciliation
mais ça n'est qu'une ça n'est qu'une
première étape parce que parce que à
côté de l'arabie saoudite il ya les
émirats arabes unis qui eux ont une
position une posture anti qatarienne
très très forte avec un élément central
qui les différencie c'est l'appui
justement qatariens aux frères musulmans
pour les émirats arabes unis c'est une
c'est une véritable obsession
les émirats arabes unis et le qatar sont
en guerre en libye notamment
et donc même si ce soir ou demain matin
plus tôt les avions vont de nouveau volé
entre doha et dubaï ce qui va rendre
service à beaucoup de business man de la
région et bien eu la méfiance qui
existait entre le qatar et les laver et
les émirats n'a pas ne va pas remettre
du jour au lendemain donc voilà il
faudra voir un petit peu comment cette
réouverture des relations diplomatiques
va se passer il est déjà une crise en
2014 lorsque ces mêmes pays avaient
retiré leur ambassadeur du qatar pour
pour manifester leur colère contre ce
qu'ils considèrent comme un un appui
qatariens musulman est il trop grande
proximité avec l'iran c'est le crise n'a
même pas été ya eu quelques petits
gestes qui avait été adoptée par le
qatar insuffisant pour ses voisins ya eu
la crise de 2010 est aujourd'hui à
nouveau une réconciliation mais il
faudra voir un petit peu comment ça se
passe dans la réalité est dans les
détails ça sera assez compliqué je pense
alors vous parliez de joe biden georges
malbrunot mais enfin en attendant il y
avait un petit peu l'ombre de donald
trump qui planait sur 7
réconciliation avec la présence de yared
cashner legendre et conseiller du
président sortant qui présent ce qui
n'était évidemment pas fortuite
c'est une sorte de nouvelle victoire
diplomatique de donald trump
avant de partir en tout cas c'est la
dernière devrait semblablement rappel on
peut le supposer
mais c'était effectivement une victoire
diplomatique vous faites bien de le
rappeler il y avait jared kushner qui a
été l'artisan justement ce rapprochement
entre l'arabie saoudite entre son combat
on peut le dire avec bin salman
et puis et puis cheikh tamim du qatar
mais pour moi avec des deux salles mal
c'est aussi une façon de faire une
pierre deux coups il rend hommage à
jared kushner administration trump qui
le à la pop ou bd il faut se souvenir de
la faire caca shogi donald trump a sauvé
littéralement mohammed salman est donc
aujourd'hui nbs mohammed bin salman lui
renvoie l'ascenseur en finalement
offrant à l'administration américaine
sortante une dernière victoire
diplomatique
et puis domaine trop c'est ce que je
disais par la même occasion c'est ce que
disait qui est bien ils déchargent jo
byden du crise la gestion d'une crise
entre alliés donc oui il ya
effectivement l'héritage de cette
administration américaine qui a réussi
effectivement à force de pression avec
la médiation du koweït a affaire que
bien l'arabie saoudite le qatar et les
émirats et bien se réconcilier en tout
cas amorce une réconciliation mais qui
encore une fois tu vas être va être
difficile à régler parce que parce qu'en
fait vous l'avez compris les racines des
tensions et bien les problèmes n'ont pas
été respectées traiter le qatar restera
toujours un supporter de l'islam
politique est d'être un musulman le
qatar restera toujours alliée avec la
turquie le qatar gardé de bonnes
relations avec l'iran et tout ça risque
de continuer de déplaire effectivement
c'est vrai alors tout est une question
de mesure il pourrait y avoir une
diminution la présence militaire turque
à doha il pourrait y avoir il va y avoir
en tout cas c'est sur une réduction
la propagande anti saoudienne et anti
américaines sur al jazeera c'est vers ça
il y aura aussi beaucoup moins d'
attaques sur les chaîne saoudienne et
gris yens contre le qatar m voilà le
lever le diable se cache dans le détail
et ça va être ça va être très compliqué
de réinstaurer la confiance y compris
entre les peuples parce qu'elle est
beaucoup d'eux ait eu beaucoup de
il ya une véritable guerre de l'ombre
guerre de l'information qui a eu lieu
ces dernières années sur les réseaux
sociaux des attaques personnelles etc
même si notamment aux qatariens et
saoudiens c'est souvent les mêmes tribus
avec le même nom donc la halle ces
tribus étaient séparées aujourd'hui ils
vont pouvoir se rencontrer
il ya encore beaucoup beaucoup
d'acrimonie beaucoup de ressentiment et
et le pour apaiser tout cela eh bien il
faudra du temps merci beaucoup en tout
cas georges malbrunot grand reporter au
figaro spécialiste du moyen-orient merci
à vous de nous avoir apporté votre
éclairage et c'est la fin de cette
émission se retrouve dans quelques
minutes avant 2 heures pour un point
complet sur l'actualité
[Musique]
l'hypothèse de rendre obligatoire le
vaccin pose problème ce qui est en cause
c'est votre liberté
mais ce qui est en cause aussi